almost all cross-testing to kill or
pacify scp-682 had failed miserably if
you haven't seen it go watch our video
on the legendary hard to kill reptile to
see just how powerful and terrifying
this creature is it faced the gate
Guardian an SCP with a flaming sword
hotter than the sun capable of tearing
your atoms to shreds and came out fine
in its Face-Off with a horrifying
scp-096 also known as the shy guy it
broke the Shy Guy's mind and reduced it
to gibbering despair even scps with
supposedly unlimited Powers simply
refused to engage the beast in combat
so when it was proposed that they test
682 with scp-999 a creature known among
Foundation staff as the Tickle Monster
the idea was considered laughable 682
had been burned suffocated cut up
incinerated and growled in the faces of
the Gods how could this so-called Tickle
Monster ever hope to survive an
encounter let alone win a fight some
even believe that this was the last we'd
see of scp-999 but what makes this story
truly remarkable is that that isn't how
this played out as you'll soon discover
scp-999 is an amazing and unique SCP in
and of itself
but its secret Origins and its
interactions with some other prominent
figures in the SCP Universe are what
make this humble slimy creature Beyond
extraordinary
prepare yourself for the heartwarming
Yes you heard that right the
heartwarming story of scp-999
several highly trained agents on 682
detail Place 999 into the immortal
lizard cell compared to the giant
reptilian sitting across from it 999
wasn't much to look at it's a large
orange amorphous blob of anomalous slime
weighing in at around 120 pounds scp-999
was nothing compared to the monstrosity
it was supposed to face while its weight
has in the past cause minor injuries to
some of its human handlers it has never
caused serious or long-lasting damage of
any kind to a living thing even its diet
consists only of candy and sweets with a
particular preference for M M's and Neko
Wafers it consumes these treats through
the cell membrane of its slimy body much
like an amoeba this extremely stretchy
membrane means the creature is highly
malleable including the ability to
stretch and flatten itself out to a mere
two centimeters thick at rest the
creature takes a dome-like shape around
2 meters wide and one meter in height
the closest things the creature has to
limbs are prehenso pseudopods those are
the arm-like projections normally seen
on single-celled organisms of which it
has at least three the more you hear
about this utterly harmless creature the
more that matching it up with the pure
embodiment of absolute hatred known as
scp-682 feels downright cruel in
absolute contrast to the misanthropic
attitudes of the reptile 999 loves
humans it has a playful dog-like
attitude much like an over-excited puppy
when approached 999 will react with
extreme joy and slithered towards the
nearest person in order to interact it
will leap onto them using two of its
three prehensile pseudopods to hug the
person while the third nuzzles the
person's face emitting high-pitched
cooing and gurgling noises throughout
the creature is apparently Pleasant in
every conceivable fashion as even its
odor has been reported to smell just
like the favorite scent of whoever is
smelling it examples have included
chocolate fresh laundry bacon roses and
Play-Doh it's almost impossible to
oversell just how beloved and benevolent
this strange creature is it's one of the
rare Sapient scps to earn the safe class
and it's allowed to roam freely around
its facility at all times apart from a
one-hour bedtime period between 8 and 9
pm in the rare instances that 999 has
caused harm to a worker at the facility
it immediately began to back away and
contract its body while whimpering in a
kind of dog-like apology
the closest the foundation has ever come
to having a real incident with the
creature was the time someone
accidentally fetted a can of caffeinated
Cola causing it to become hyper for an
hour before becoming visibly queasy
you'll be relieved to know that it's
since made a full recovery
but what would happen when this
Whimsical creature is forced to go
toe-to-toe with the foundation's most
ill-tempered Monster the employees
observing the test watched in suspense
as 999 began to enthusiastically Slither
towards 682. it's no surprise that after
being tortured and almost killed
hundreds of times during testing 682 had
grown jaded to the Cross tests it was
regularly subjected to when it saw this
strange orange blob squelching across
the ground towards it its side and
groaned expecting the worst
what is that the creature asked of its
gelatinous guest
scp-999 began jumping up and down in
front of 682 like an excited puppy
creating a high-pitched squealing noise
just as it regarded all living things
682 thought the creature bouncing around
before it was disgusting and hardly
worth the effort to destroy was the
foundation even trying anymore with a
single vicious stomp 682 flattened the
friendly creature beneath one of its
feet observers were prepared to charge
in and liberate 999 from under 682's
claws but then something truly
unexpected happened the expression on
682's acid eaten face began to slowly
change it was beginning to smile
observers recorded a noise what they
thought could have been a chuckle as the
creature growled and said
what is this
I feel good
while The Observers looked on stunned at
what was happening 999 began to Slither
and crawl up from between 682's toes
reformed on its scaly leg and slithered
up along its side until it reached the
neck there it began to nuzzle like it
had never nuzzled before the results
spoke for themselves 682 was grinning
and chuckling repeating a phrase that
the foundation never would have imagined
coming from 682
feel so happy happy
just when you thought scp-999 couldn't
possibly be more adorable you learn
about its greatest power bringing Joy
anyone and anything that comes into
contact with the creature even in
passing will experience a kind of mild
Euphoria as one's contact with the
creature is prolonged this overwhelming
sense of Joy increases and continues
long after you've separated from it
prolonged contact has completely cured
depression anxiety and PTSD along with a
number of other conditions including
rage and anti-social personality
disorders serial killers practically
become Saints after coming into
prolonged contact with 999 and in that
moment 682 was no exception and there
truly does not appear to be no
exceptions while causing happiness and
joy isn't a dangerous weapon when it
comes to scp-999 it is an extremely
powerful one and what's more scp-999
also appears to have an innate sense for
those who need its help most with a
particular affection for the hurt and
the unhappy the creature appears to be
at true altruist on a fundamental level
even risking its own safety to help
humans during dangerous containment
breaches in one dramatic instance 999
leaped into the air to block a bullet
from making contact with a member of
staff
as a result the creature is pretty much
universally loved by all members of
foundation staff it's the one SCP who
has never made trouble for anyone back
in scp-682's containment cell the Beast
was still smiling and laughing as 999
rubbed against its neck it was an event
so strange so unprecedented that The
Observers in attendance felt like they
were hallucinating for a few minutes the
monster kept dreamly repeating the word
happy but then suddenly the creature
began to enter a fit of uncontrollable
booming laughter it rolled onto its back
slamming its huge tail against the door
it had just Fallen victim to one of
999's favorite pastimes tickle fights
hence how it earned its Tickle Monster
nickname among staff
the tickle fight continued until 682
appeared to tire and fall asleep with a
smile still on its face after 15 minutes
of inactivity two d-class Personnel were
commanded to enter and retrieve scp-999
from the containment cell they did so
successfully but as soon as 999 was
removed 682 roused from its Lumber and
released a powerful psychic attack from
its entire body while laughing
maniacally it rendered all Personnel
within a certain distance incapacitated
as they collapsed in fits of laughter
allowing 682 to escape and go on a
violent Rampage
however in spite of this 999 showed no
fear and helped save some of the
bystanders as security officers subdued
and recaptured 682 and even after all of
this 999 showed no hard feelings towards
682 and indicated a desire to play again
it's a creature whose capacity for love
is so Limitless that it's practically
immune to fear which is all well and
good because the true enemy that 999 is
destined to face is infinitely more
powerful and terrifying than 682 could
ever hope to be what is this monster and
why should 999 have to face it someday
the answers to these questions all lie
in the true origins of scp-999 available
only to those with level 5 clearance and
Beyond it's a perfect example of how
something good can come from the darkest
places there would be no scp-9999
without
scp-231-7
scp-231 was a collection of seven girls
all impregnated by horrific nightmares
in a ritual perform formed by a cult
known as the children of the Scarlet
King
these girls over the years that followed
gave birth to some of the most horrific
monsters imaginable
one of which According to some was
scp-682
these beings were manifested by the
Scarlet King a powerful interdimensional
nightmare God believed to be behind a
great deal of the darkness and horror
present within R and many other
dimensions Foundation higher-ups have
declared the Scarlet King to be the
greatest existing threat to the
Multiverse at large an scp-231 was his
latest direct interaction with our
universe
the only surviving member of scp-231
scp-231-7 gave birth in secret but she
didn't give birth to a monster she gave
birth to scp-999 a being of pure
goodness that's right the nicest kindest
cuddliest SCP of all is the direct
descendant of a being that's essentially
the dark God of all evil feel free to
take a moment to absorb that
the creature even healed the girl who
birthed it and allowed her to return to
normal life with her family once more
from its first moments scp-999 was
making positive changes to the world
around it and according to ancient texts
from a Scarlet King aligned culture
known as the DeVos
scp-999 is still very much in its
infancy yet it already has the power to
pacify its monstrous siblings like the
aforementioned 682
it's believed According to some
prophecies and Foundation theories that
the power of scp-9999 will grow
exponentially as it matures
why does this matter well it's believed
by some that one day 999 will grow
powerful enough to overthrow not only
its own monstrous siblings but the
thought to be unstoppable Scarlet King
himself not through violence or hate but
through the pure force of happiness and
love burning out the darkness and
purifying the corrupted
while the humble scp-999 rarely
outshines its frightening competitors to
those truly in the know 999 is one of
the most powerful and valuable scps in
existence and may be the greatest asset
in the foundation's Arsenal for the war
against dangerous anomalous activity
after all what could strike more fear
into their hearts than the knowledge
that it might be love rather than
Firepower that finally dethrones the
Scarlet King
and for the knowledge that it may one
day save everything we know from a fate
so much worse than death with nothing
but affection for everyone and
everything it's worth offering thanks to
the little orange blob or at least an
extra pack of M M's before bedtime
[Music]
on March 15 2011 Martin Sims was
wandering down the streets of Carson
California his clothes were ranked he
was filthy and gibbering like a madman
with a full beard and long uncamped hair
his body was covered in scars but he
showed no signs of malnutrition what
made Martin's sudden appearance so
remarkable he'd been missing for three
years when he was interviewed by police
they asked him where he'd been all this
time they couldn't believe his answer
he'd been trapped in an Ikea since 2008
but this was no ordinary Ikea this was a
dangerous anomaly that would come to be
known as
scp-3008 Martin strange answers in his
interview were left off by his
interviewing officers who assumed he was
either crazy or under the influence of
something but they caught the attention
of an SCP Foundation field agent
embedded in the precinct the report was
passed up the chain to a local site
director who approved a Detachment of
foundation field operatives to look into
Martin's case while he was reluctant to
lead the foundation agents back to the
offending Ikea the foundation can be
extremely persuasive his screams of
please I'm begging you don't take me
back don't make me go back we're noted
But ultimately disregarded when the SCP
Foundation had triangulated the position
of scp-3008 which was indeed an active
Ikea the entire retail Zone was closed
and barricaded under the pretense of a
severe black mold infestation armed
Foundation Personnel also arrived on the
site shortly after based on Martin's
vague statements that there were
creatures of some kind inside due to his
deteriorating mental health Martin was
unable to provide a great deal of lucid
information on the specific traits of
scp-3008 but one phrase he kept
repeating was bigger on the inside once
researchers were satisfied that Martin
had delivered all the pertinent
information he was able to he was
administered Foundation amnestics to
erase his memory of the last three years
and returned to his family a cover story
was formulated Martin had been kidnapped
and abused for three years by a mentally
unbalanced stalker in downtown Carson
he'd been able to escape as said Stocker
took his own life out of guilt a suicide
that the foundation expertly fabricated
to make their cover story airtight with
the loose end of Martin Sims taken care
of the true observation of scp-3008
could begin a base set around the
perimeter of the mysterious Ikea kept
the 24-hour watch on the building
covering all potential entrances and
exits no exploratory missions had yet
been approved by the foundation Ethics
Committee so they first wanted to
perform a week of external observation
to see if any of the store's anomalous
properties extended beyond the confines
of the building after a week of nothing
it appeared they did not a local site
director approved of the use of 20
disposable class D Personnel to explore
the interior of scp-3008 the d-class
operatives would be split into four
squads of five men alpha bravo charlie
and Delta Squad each would be assigned a
different quadrant of the store and
would deliver information back to the
control team on site via a live audio
and video link three of the 4 teams upon
entering the store reported nothing out
of the ordinary neither the audio or
video they were sending back indicated
anything different from a standard IKEA
store from the flat pack wardrobes to
the Swedish meatballs Team Delta however
suddenly began experiencing a scrambled
Audio and Video Connection shortly after
communication with Team Delta dropped
off entirely they disappeared somewhere
inside the store and haven't been seen
since with one notable exception after
The Disappearance and the extraction of
teams Foundation researchers classified
scp-3008 as Euclid because its anomalous
properties were at least confined to the
interior of the store and even then
seemingly not the entire interior the
anomalous area within scp-3008 became
known as
scp-3008-1 and containment appeared to
be 100 secure there was no telling how
many people had already gone missing in
the store over the years but the
disappearances Must Be Stopped the
foundation maintained constant
surveillance around the perimeter of
scp-3008 but it appeared they could
prevent any further incidents by simply
preventing other civilians from
accessing the IKEA store Martin's
ravings about monsters were assumed to
just be the product of delirium until a
surviving member of Delta team suddenly
reappeared the date was November 3rd
2011 it was a cold night a few hours
after what would have been closing time
if the store were still active and seven
months after the extraction teams had
disappeared somewhere in the confines of
scp-3008 there had been no anomalous
activity outside the store since the
perimeter was first secured and the
foundation researchers hadn't expected
that to change until the last surviving
member of Delta team came barging out of
the store's entrance startled field
operatives were amazed to see him again
but they were even more amazed to see
what was following him out of the store
repeating the same phrase the store is
now closed please exit the building
despite the fact that the entity chasing
the Delta team Survivor was wearing the
yellow shirt and blue pants of an Ikea
store employee the being definitely was
not human it was around seven feet tall
with no visible face The Entity had
grossly extended limbs with each arm
being around five or six feet long and
ending in a huge oversized hand the
whole process was so sudden that the
field agents present at the perimeter
weren't able to save the delts team
Survivor as the entity reached forward
with this freakishly long arms grabbed
him and twisted his head off like a
child with a doll the field operatives
present Drew their weapons and peppered
The Entity with bullets it would later
be classified as
scp-3008-2 the being appeared to
collapse and die from the physical
trauma at which point it and the body of
the former Delta team Survivor were
taken for an autopsy by Foundation
researchers there were no biological
abnormalities of the body of the Delta
team Survivor so it did not appear that
the anomalous properties of scp-3008-1
had any effect on the physiology of its
occupants he was not malnourished
despite being missing for months and the
contents of his stomach looked to be
half digested food consistent with the
menu of a typical IKEA store restaurant
scp-3008-2 on the other hand raised a
number of perplexing biological
questions the autopsy revealed that the
creature's clothes were actually part of
its body like an additional layer of
skin the creature lacked blood or any
kind of vascular system even stranger
The Entity didn't appear to have bones
or internal organs not even a brain or
nervous system it was a being made
entirely of skin all the way to its core
how it was able to move or even live for
that matter remains a mystery though
when he worked for the SCP Foundation
you learned to accept that some things
will always remain unexplained one thing
was certain though Martin Sims was right
about his monsters after the incident
with Delta team the foundation deemed
that sending manned Explorations Into
the Heart of scp-3008 was too much of a
liability and planned a series of
drone-based reconnaissance missions into
the anomaly the first of these drones
experienced connection issues and failed
when attempting to venture into the
Ikea's anomalous Zone however after a
lengthy period of trial and error the
foundation was able to establish a more
secure connection with its drones even
went deep into the scp-3008-1 anomalous
Zone it was only then that that some of
the most extraordinary discoveries were
made
scp-3008-1 seemed to break the laws of
spatial reality as the area of the
Ikea's interior was at least an order of
magnitude larger than its exterior just
as Martin Sims it said it was bigger on
the inside but just how much bigger the
foundation has yet to find evidence of
any physical Terminators within the
store that might indicate scp-3008-1 has
an end point while an area of at least
10 kilometers squared has been uncovered
in scp-3008-1 it could in theory be
infinite Laser Rangefinder tests which
are normally very reliable have only
given inconclusive results interestingly
the anomalous area doesn't have any
clear visual differences from the rest
of the IKEA store except that it extends
forever an individual trapped within the
confines of scp-3008-1 wouldn't even
realize they've entered an anomalous
zone until they tried to locate an exit
and leave at which point they'd find
they were already hopelessly lost the
geography of scp-3008-1 does at least
appear to be assistant so people trapped
within are theoretically able to retrace
their steps and Escape if they haven't
already ventured too deep according to
data collected during the Drone
reconnaissance missions
scp-3008-2 of which there appear to be a
vast population would wander the stores
aimlessly during the day they are
unresponsive to the drone's presence and
did not appear to be aggressive while
the physical descriptions of these
creatures could vary slightly they all
follow the same overall trend clothes
consistent with an Ikea uniform no face
either seemingly Too Tall or too short
and limbs that are grossly out of
proportion with their bodies as the
foundation began sending drones deeper
and scp-3008-1 they found another
incredible Discovery there was an
unknown population of humans trapped
inside Ikea's anomalous Zone and these
people had used the IKEA furniture
around them to create entire settlements
and towns within the store there were
several of these towns all of which
seemed to cohabitate peacefully even
Foundation Personnel found this
development in their research to be
truly extraordinary since
scp-3008 was first identified there have
been only 14 civilian escapes some had
been trapped inside for months others
had been in there for years some far
longer than Martin's three-year stint
while every one of these escapees has
eventually been released back to their
home after a liberal application of
amnestics in a proper cover story has
been devised the foundation interviewed
each of them extensively first according
to each of these escapees the people
trapped inside the Ikea have built an
entirely new Society across the various
settlements contrary to the Lord of the
Flies expectations of a group of people
isolated and afraid there's immense
cooperation between the trapped
civilians the food in the several Ikea
restaurants in scp-3008-1 mysteriously
replenishes while nobody's there so
there's no threat of starving and the
automatic turning on and off of the
lights forms as a rudimentary kind of
day and night cycle nighttime however is
when things get dangerous as the
scp-3008-2 entities which are known to
the people inside as the staff become
extremely hot hostile after dark
aggressive hordes of the staff swarmed
the settlements at night repeating this
door is now closed please exit the
building the civilians inside are
usually able to repel these attacks with
minimal casualties but the constant War
of Attrition slowly wears down those
inside the bodies of the creatures also
need to be removed from the area after
each attack as the presence of corpses
or even parts of corpses has been known
to heighten the ferocity of the next
night's attack during the day the staff
returned to a docile and unresponsive
State though they'll still defend
themselves violently if anyone dares to
attack over the course of the interviews
with the 14 escapees Foundation
researchers were able to answer another
of their key questions how had so many
people gone missing in the store for so
long without being noticed but the
answer they received only raised many
more unsettling queries according to the
escapees there were people inside the
settlements that despite being otherwise
of entirely sound mind and standard
intelligence seem to lack very common
knowledge that even a child should know
for example some of them weren't aware
of the International Space Station or
orbiting the Earth or stranger still the
existence of the Statue of Liberty this
led the researchers to a frightening
conclusion
scp-3008-1 may not only be a Nexus point
of multiple Ikea stores in our Dimension
it could be connected to Ikea's in every
Dimension where Ikeas exist while it
only abducts a handful of people from
each store over an extended period of
time it suddenly becomes clear how this
SCP was able to trap so many people
without detection over such a long
period of time which in turn led to an
even more terrifying Revelation the SCP
Foundation may not have scp-3008-1 as
contained as they thought it might even
be tucked away in an Ikea store
somewhere near you just waiting for you
to visit after all there's always room
for one more
when an anomaly is first detected by an
SCP Foundation field agent it's up to
the foundation's mobile task forces to
tag and bag The Impossible entities
before they can do any more harm
sometimes these retrievals are
uneventful other times not so much
especially when they're dealing with
brutal forces of nature like
scp-096 also known as the shy guy a
creature that from the very first
interaction with the foundation had a
reputation for being dangerous and
needed to be feared a series of vague
sightings and mysterious disappearances
up in the frosty mountains of the Yukon
first Sparks the foundation's interest
when they were certain that they had an
anomaly on their hands two retrieval
teams Zulu 9A and Zulu 9B were
dispatched to secure and contain the
entity Zulu 9A took the lead in a heavy
duty Chopper equipped with 50 caliber
gau-19 heavy machine guns and carrying
an at4 anti-tank launch sure they were
prepared for anything or so they thought
as they established a visual on scp-096
while two clicks away from the target
they couldn't get a clear line of sight
on the creature but it appeared to be
stationary docile and was making no
attempt to Flay piece of cake right
little did they know that scp-096 was
just looking away from them if it was
facing towards them it'd be a whole
different Horror Story as
about to find out the team landed their
helicopter next to the creature and were
shocked to see that it was completely
naked in spite of the Sub-Zero
temperatures all around them the
creature was unnaturally thin as though
had been starved for weeks with bone
white skin and unnaturally long limbs
the team guessed that the creature's
arms must have been at least 1.5 meters
long but its docile nature an
insubstantial body mass gave the
impression that it would improve too
difficult to contain that is until they
saw its face Zulu 9a's Captain was the
Lone Survivor of the incident as he was
lucky enough to be looking away when the
creature turned towards his team the
rest of the squad ended up staring eye
to eye with scp-096 and from that moment
on wasn't docile anymore the creature
began to whimper then cry then SOB
uncontrollably in a way that sounded
eerily human this Sudden Change in
temperament startled the rest of zulu 9A
and they opened fire on the creature
under the hail of gunfire scp-09 6
entered a murderous frenzy and began
tearing into the hapless Squad of
soldiers while its flesh and organs did
seem to take damage as a result of the
barrage of 50 caliber rounds from the
helicopter mounted machine guns
skeletal structure remained intact and
it continued its Onslaught tearing the
team Lim from limb even after they'd
blown practically all the flesh from the
creature the at4 anti-tank launcher
proved equally ineffective at stopping
scp-096 while it was in attack mode
it was only after slaughtering the
entire team that had returned to its
docile State nobody knows exactly what
the creature did to Zulu 9A after the
gunfire started but no trace of the team
was left behind
Zulu 9B touched down soon after and with
a grave warning from the captain not to
look at the creature's face they were
finally able to subdue it a bag was
placed over scp-096's face which seemed
to soothe it enough to move it to a
nearby Foundation facility little did
they know they just obtained one of the
deadliest scps of all time and while it
may have been under lock and key for now
it seemed inevitable that it would get
out and cause more violence and Chaos
research and containment procedures for
the scp-096 were put under the command
of Dr Dan a senior researcher at the
site it was his job to find out exactly
what this being was capable of the more
he tested the more he realized that they
were dealing with something truly
terrifying disposable d-class Personnel
were used to figure out exactly what it
was that caused the creature to enter
its Attack Mode just as it had during
the initial retrieval Mission
scp-096 went berserk when any of the
attending Personnel saw its face in this
stage it would enter a period of
considerable and Unstoppable distress
for one to two minutes covering its face
and wailing loudly when the period of
distress ended the creature would
mercilessly Slaughter every d-class that
had seen its face and just like with
Zulu 9A no trace of their bodies would
be left behind
Dr Den was horrified and intrigued by
this phenomenon the creature killed
anyone that saw its face directly but
could the same be said for indirect
depictions of the creature's face such
as images and videos Dr Dan was
desperate to find out more d-class
Personnel were brought in to test this
to frightening results Dr Dan found that
the creature did indeed still enter
Attack Mode when people saw pictures and
videos of scp-096's face the creatures
seemed to have an innate sense of when
people were viewing these
representations even when it should have
had no conceivable way of knowing it
didn't matter how far away or how many
barriers were in place between the
viewer and the creature the attack mode
would still activate and once it did it
seemed as though nothing could stop the
creature from hunting down the one who
saw its face with all this new data
special containment procedures were
devised to keep the creature safely
under lock and key its cell was a 5
meter by 5 meter by five meter airtight
steel Cube fitted with Advanced pressure
sensors and Laser detectors to ensure
that scp-096 remained in itself without
risking anyone having visual contact
with the creature's face all cameras and
video equipment were strictly forbidden
and weekly checks for any cracks or
holes in the containment cell were
mandatory of course none of this would
stop the Creature if anyone somehow saw
its face in order to solve that little
problem Dr Dan would need to continue
his research
to find a method of subverting the
creature's deadly glance they needed to
know exactly what they were dealing with
but how could they when even a glance at
a photo or video of the being meant
certain death
a potential solution was proposed
creating an artistic representation of
the creature's face something that
hadn't yet been attempted but how would
they achieve such a fee simple they'd
procure a d-class prisoner with some
artistic talent and they found one who
had been a tattoo artist before becoming
a foundation guinea pig Dr Dan
formulated an ingenious plan for keeping
this d-class alive for long enough to
accurately draw an image of
scp-096's face you would placed in a
bathosphere diving bell several
kilometers underwater and tens of
kilometers away from the containment
cell where the SCP was being held the
d-class was made to look at a photograph
of the creature's face and then
replicate that image in a pencil sketch
Dr Dan first confirmed that the
creature's Attack Mode is only activated
by the creature's face by having the
d-class look at a series of photos of
the scp's body parts one by one finally
finishing with its face the d-class
began drawing and even remarked on how
creepy the scp's facial features were
despite not knowing the Dudley context
meanwhile back in its containment cell
scp-096 sends someone viewing its face
and entered its inconsolable crying
State followed by its Attack Mode it
broke out of containment easily and
began making a beeline for the d-class
traversing the miles between it and its
prey the d-class didn't know it as he
locked the finished drawing into a
separate autonomous submersible but he
was already dead
as the drawing made its way up to a
researcher on the surface
scp-096 divd into the water and started
swimming down towards the artist minutes
later the bathysphere was breached
Trends
scp-096 was recaptured without issue by
surface recovery team foxtrot 303a and
further testing on the drawing showed
that artistic representations of
scp-096's face were in fact harmless
from this experience we now know that
the creature has a gaunt face with
totally white eyes possibly indicating
blindness and a grossly extended jaw
nevertheless Dr Dan was adamant that
scp-096 was too dangerous to be left
alive and requested permission from the
upper echelons of the foundation to
terminate the creature by any means
necessary however the doctor's request
would fall on deaf ears until it all
started with a seemingly innocent image
while it's now been redacted for your
safety the blacks back inside the yellow
circle was once a minuscule image of
scp-096 taken unknowingly in the 1990s
by a semi-professional mountaineer one
day they were looking at Old photographs
when his eyes passed over the tiny Speck
without even noticing that he had seen
but scp-096 noticed and began entering
its Attack Mode it tore through its
steel containment unit like tissue paper
causing the release of a nerve agent
that killed a number of attending
Foundation staff the monster then fled
the base and began pursuing its prey
with mobile task force Tau 1 and Hot
Pursuit Dr Alexey was helping to manage
the site where the SCP was contained was
in dismay over the situation Dr Dan was
out of the country at the time trying to
discover more about the creature's
Origins however he did leave the mobile
task force with a new secret weapon
against the rampaging Shy Guy project
scramble scramble were state-of-the-art
goggles featuring a new technology
created by Dr Dan which using artistic
Renditions of 096's facial features
could detect and scramble the features
of scp-096 into an unrecognizable form
preventing the normally deadly effect of
gazing upon its face in theory this
would allow MTF tal1 to engage safely
with 096 Once its prey had been
eliminated and bring it back into
but disaster struck on two fronts first
the praying question was located in a
population Center creating the potential
for a huge loss of life and the second
bigger problem was that the scramble
technology didn't work as straight
pixels of the creature's face would
reach the eyes of the task force before
the internal microprocessor had time to
scramble them the mission turned into a
death sentence as scp-096 slaughtered
almost the entire task force as well as
a number of civilians in town including
an infant and its entire family who was
a Monumental disaster made even worse by
a final Revelation Dr Dan and Dr Alexi
had themselves facilitated the entire
Containment Breach and allowed the
resulting Massacre to happen with Dr Dan
hoping it would be enough motivation for
foundation command to Green Light his
research into destroying the creature
anything that would give him the
opportunity to kill this thing would be
worth the bloodshot his plan worked and
the SCP Foundation saw it his way
approving his request to neutralize SCP
096 however success comes at a cost for
Dr Dan once he figures out a way to
finally kill the creature though done in
his line of duty he himself will be
terminated by the foundation for his
crimes against humanity but considering
how much damage scp-096 is capable of
causing if it ever got to a major
population Center or even worse was ever
caught on camera and broadcast to a
worldwide audience the doctor himself
would likely deem his own death a
justifiable cost to this day the
foundation is researching ways to kill
the creature and they're still looking
for their Silver Bullet and the pressure
is on they hadn't known about the
seemingly innocent picture that sparked
the last containment Bridge the one
taken decades ago in which the shy guy
had only occupied four tiny pixels four
tiny pixels that resulted in multiple
innocent lives lost
so be careful where you look because who
knows how many other photos of the
creature are lurking up there photos
with an innocent dot in the background
your eyes glance over it not even
noticing the little blip until you hear
a distant wailing that seems to be
getting closer and closer and closer and
then it's already too late
scp-682 must be destroyed as soon as
possible
so Begins the SCP Foundation file on the
dreaded scp-682 a highly intelligent
reptilian monster that has despite the
foundation's best efforts proved
impossible to kill it may not be the
most dangerous SCP out there considering
that some are capable of eliminating
entire realities but it's one of the
most iconic and you've probably heard
tales of the monster that death forgot
and you know exactly why everyone is so
afraid of the so-called hard to kill
reptile it's been subjected to some of
the most deadly weapons and traps the
foundation could devise and survived
attacks from some of its deadliest
fellow scps but before we tell you about
the foundation's many failed
assassination attempts against the
so-called hard to kill reptile we need a
little more groundwork on what this
creature even is the first thing to know
about scp-682 is that this thing wants
you and everything you know dead
unlike some other creatures like scp-096
and SCP-173 which are murderous but
exhibit no real higher processing skills
scp-682 possesses cunning Advanced
reasoning and even human level logical
intelligence
scp-682 can engage you in conversation
but just talking to the creature calmly
and cordially will sometimes cause it to
enter its rage stay where it becomes
even more dangerous and volatile the
Beast is perpetually kept in a tank of
powerful hydrochloric acid melting its
tissue to prevent it from reaching its
full potential and going on a rampage
the creature's most terrifying asset and
the reason it's proven impossible to
terminate thus far is its incredible
adaptability to any and all external
stimuli 682 is a reactive being capable
of not only surviving and regenerating
from all attacks but often incorporating
those attacks into its own wide Arsenal
in other words if you're hoping to kill
this thing you better kill it on the
first hit
because if you don't you better believe
it's gonna hit you back a hundred times
harder
this brings us to the main event some of
the SCP foundation's most ambitious and
frightening attempts to terminate
scp-682 or even understand how it could
theoretically be terminated there are
quite literally too many unsuccessful
attempts for us to list them all here so
think of this as a highlight reel of the
foundation's most prominent failures 682
was first cross-tested with scp-017 a
humanoid Shadow entity shown to be able
to consume matter with its shadows and
leave no traces behind test on tissue
samples from 682 showed that scp-017 was
able to consume said tissues with no
adverse effects however when scp-017 was
placed into the containment chamber with
the actual creature 682 let out a
horrific Roar that was so loud it
damaged nearby audio equipment
scp-017 fled to the corner of the room
and 682 in its rage State attempted to
breach containment agents managed to
suppress and remove the creature but no
meaningful damage was logged attempt
failed
SCP-173 the killer statue was later
brought in hoping that it's thus far
impeccable track record for killing
would hold strong the second that 173
was introduced into the testing area 682
retreated to the far wall and began
screeching intensely it was intelligent
enough to know what it was dealing with
here while the researchers and guards
expected an instantaneous reaction there
was actually a stalemate for over six
hours as 682 stared at 173 continuously
eventually the tie was broken when
agents shot out 682's eyes with high
caliber sniper rifles breaking the line
of sight and causing 173 to attack
though 682 sustained damage to several
parts of its body while its eyes were
generated the creature was not killed it
then regenerated a number of eyes all
over its body covered in a clear armored
carapace that made them resistant to
bullets the stalemate continued for an
additional 12 hours as 682 maintained
Perpetual eye contact 173 was eventually
removed from the containment unit and
the mission was aborted attempt failed
in their desperation the SCP Foundation
restored to bringing in another
dangerous and seemingly unkillable
monster to take on 682
scp-096 also known as the shy guy as
astute SCP fans will already know this
being kills anything that sees its face
with no known exceptions and when it
enters its attack mode it's thought to
be quite literally Unstoppable or at
least it was while scp-096 was able to
destroy 85 percent of 682's original
body mass during their 27 hour battle
it was left mentally broken wounded and
huddled in the corner to this day if
ever confronted with scp-682 the shy guy
reacts in pure Terror turning away and
clawing at its own face attempt failed
during a deadly Containment Breach
scp-682 also went head-to-head
organically with another iconic SCP Hall
of Famer
scp-106 also known as the old man the
old man and a shape-shifting psionic
anomaly known as scp-953 broke into
682's containment cell the old man
pulled both of his fellow anomalous
combatants into his pocket Dimension to
continue the battle on his terms however
despite losing 67 percent of his body
mass during the ensuing pocket Dimension
Showdown 682 still prevailed with the
old man eventually fleeing back to his
cell and 953 being collected and taken
away by agents once again
scp-682 continued to hold the title but
it wasn't just cross-testing experiments
intentional or otherwise the SCP
foundation's quest to kill 682 LED them
to a number of more conventional murder
methods all with varying degrees of
success due to scp-682's highly adaptive
abilities some methods were discounted
from the outs
for example launching a powerful
thermonuclear missile at the creature
was soundly rejected by o5 command on
the premise that if the creature wasn't
destroyed and evolved to the point where
it could shrug off nukes Humanity would
be pretty much done for other ideas were
abandoned just for being too ridiculous
such as one researcher's suggestion to
fly the creature through the air and
drop it from a considerable height
hoping to kill it with a high altitude
impact I'm not sure we even need to tell
you why that's a terrible idea but
during the experiments on scp-682 the
studies range from honest to incompetent
to straight up evil
one guest researcher fed two small
innocent children to the creature just
to see what would happen he was then
himself fed to the creature for his
sadistic Behavior which was viewed as
getting in the way of his professional
conduct after all the foundation is
meant to be cold not cruel it was
scp-682 that had the Monopoly on cruelty
the medical agents were a resounding
failure they attempted to dismember 682
with a powerful laser only to have the
creature develop reflective services
that displaced the beam and caused
catastrophic damage to the area around
it they attempted to kill the creature
by sucking all the air out of its
containment facility and create a vacuum
but it expelled a dangerous gaseous
compound that reacted violently and
exploded when air was once again
introduced into the room the foundation
used High Precision Blades to slice
scp-682 into approximately 12 000 pieces
then separated these pieces
unsurprisingly by this point this
attempt also failed the 12 000 pieces
reformed a short while later into the
fully operational killing machine we all
know and fear in one particularly
frightening display of intelligence and
adaptability the foundation attempted to
kill 682 with extreme heat but it
shielded Itself by developing a second
car Pace composed of solid helium when
Personnel entered the room following the
failed attempt on the creature's life it
shattered its helium carapace into
deadly shards that fired around the room
and shredded all Foundation Personnel in
attendance it had set a trap and that
trap had been wildly successful the
creature's ability to adapt to seemingly
any offense is unparalleled to the point
where Foundation staff have no idea how
to classify this creature whether it's
organic inorganic or even alive at all
based on any definitions we could
understand
at every turn the creature just raised
more questions what is it is it possible
to destroy it at all by any means who
was even trying to kill who here because
it certainly seemed like scp-682 had a
masterful KD ratio by now more extreme
Feats of cross-testing continued in the
foundation's growing desperation to
eliminate this monster
scp-162 which is a hypnotic ball of
sharp objects Hooks and high tension
fishing line was introduced to 682's
containment cell the hooks latched onto
the creature and tore huge portions off
including its entire lower jaw and one
of its limbs however 682 was still able
to breach containment kill 11 people and
badly wound 86 others it regenerated its
severe injuries in no time the Beast was
even taken to the domain of the gate
Guardian one of the proposals for
scp-001 the guardian had a flaming sword
hotter than the sun capable of
destroying its Targets on an atomic
level
naturally scp-682 survived and
regenerated perhaps the most fascinating
cross-test of all was between 682 and
scp-053 who manifests as a kind innocent
little girl with the unfortunate
condition of causing homicidal
tendencies in all who come into contact
with her for more than 10 minutes
the people with these Tendencies would
then attempt to harm the girl but would
immediately drop dead shortly after
leaving the girl intact the researchers
present anticipated two possible
outcomes here the optimistic outcome in
which 682 enters a rage State attack 053
and died for good and the realistic
outcome in which 682 attacks 053
possibly experiencing some minor injury
or nothing at all and 053 had to be
removed from the containment cell but
that didn't happen what did occur was
considerably more shocking than any kind
of violence when 053 entered 682's
containment chamber the monster became
uncharacteristically docile researchers
and staff were baffled and watched with
amazement as 053 approached the
terrifying Immortal Mass murdering
monster and began to play with it 682
even allowed 053 to draw on its face
with crayons researchers thought they
must have been dreaming seeing this
surreal display play out 053 even
appeared to have affection for this
unkillable misanthrope it was a a single
act in defiance of everything they
thought they knew when Foundation
Personnel entered the containment cell
to separate the two 682 went ballistic
and killed multiple guards 053 also wept
sad at being separated from her new
friend
to this day despite further testing the
foundation has no idea how or why this
happened like many details surrounding
scp-682 it shrouded in deeply
frustrating mystery
and so the tale of scp-682 continues in
spite of the foundation's best efforts
the monster continues to breach
containment and Slaughter with some
regularity taking out its seemingly
Limitless hatred for not only human
beings but anything that dares drop
breath
nobody knows where exactly the creature
is from what its true nature is or why
its ability to adapt and regenerate far
exceeds any known organism on this
planet perhaps one day through enough
research and cross-testing we can
someday answer these questions with
scientific Precision but until then we
only have one answer hatred Never Dies
it isn't easy to work for the SCP
Foundation not only is the job dangerous
you could be eaten by a giant Immortal
lizard or turned into organic Furniture
inside the world's scariest living room
but it's also insanely complicated how
do you make sense of the nonsensical
what's the definition of strange when
your career is securing containing and
protecting anomalous objects and
entities rather than a single object
location or being
scp-001 is a cluster of over 30
different proposals for potential
candidates for the prestigious 001 spot
some believe there's a true zero zero
one hidden in this group and the rest
are decoys others think that these are
all just scp's cataloged prior to the
introduction of the current
classification system some even think
that all of the proposals have a valid
claim to the scp-001 throne we're not
here to make a final judgment instead
we're going to take you on a lightning
round crash course through 31 of the
scp-001 proposals if you'd like a more
in-depth take on any of these scps let
us know in the comments but for now
there's no more time to waste after all
we got a lot to cover let's go number 31
the chief of papers this seemingly
innocent stack of paper is actually one
of the most mysterious and feared items
under the foundation's lock and key
while it appears to be a simple
confidential report every time the
papers are read it details the
appearance of a new SCP that will
inevitably be discovered soon after the
question is whether the chief of papers
is warning us about these entities or
creating them itself number 30 the
Prototype this Account Details the
capture of an incredibly strained
cycloptic creature that emits massive
amounts of radiation and can create
micro singularities the writing of this
creature's file is so basic unformatted
and unredacted that it's clear that the
being was one of our earlier creatures
secured by the organization
interestingly it was during the capture
of this creature that Dr Keeter was
killed inspiring the creation of the
infamous Keeter class in his honor
number 29 the gate guard this huge
multi-winged sword-wielding biblical
energy being may have been the impetus
for the founding of the SCP Foundation
this being remains largely static
guarding the intersection of the Tigris
and Euphrates rivers its flaming sword
which is believed to be as hot as the
sun can cleave any aggressor out of
existence at the atomic level when the
founder of the SCP Foundation First
encountered the gate Guardian they heard
one word echoing through their mind
prepare and the rest is history number
28 the lock this Onyx gemstone and the
incredibly complex lock attached to it
are still a mystery to this day all
attempts to open it have failed
personally we think that's probably for
the best number 27 the factory as the
name suggests this SCP is literally a
factory founded by a pagan and a devil
worshiper while it's believed that the
factory could create just about anything
its specialty was creating a number of
scps we know and fear today
pre-foundation forces were able to
disable the factory but not without
sustaining their own heavy losses number
two 26 the spiral path this is a normal
appearing gravel pathway that when
traveled clockwise appears completely
normal however when traveled
counterclockwise the path goes uphill
forever in defiance of all laws and
physics this simple anomaly opened a
Pandora's box of rampant anomaly
creation leading to a number of the
deadly scps we know today number 25 the
Legacy this SCP is a collection of
seemingly random objects including a
diary from a person claiming to be from
another reality attempting to Halt a
trans-dimensional corruption that they
themselves created the diary claims to
have a solution to this corruption but
the solution has not yet been found
number 24 the database in one of the
strangest twists on the format this SCP
is actually the various authors of the
SCP Wiki who are somehow leaking top
secret information to the public number
23 the foundation this SCP first
discovered by the FBI is an anomalous
High School building that experiences
shifting internal geometry and sometimes
manifests hostile humanoids within
number 22 36 one of the rare benevolent
scps the 36 are humans with a truly
remarkable ability they can dampen or
even neutralize any SCP they come into
contact with though it's implied that
the 36 may have the power to save the
world every time one of them dies a
supernatural Calamity occurs often
leaving hundreds of Innocents dead
number 21 keter duty this refers to a
containment facility largely filled with
keter-class scps whose presence around
each other creates a kind of mutually
assured cancellation if one of these
scp's breaches containment that's bad
news but if all of them do it'll produce
a bubble of reality Distortion that will
fundamentally alter reality as we know
it for all we know it may have even
happened already number 20 oroboros this
is a proposal that's formed of four
sub-proposals remember what we said
about complicated these sub proposals
include the children nine anomalous kids
who emit radiation and have destructive
potential when together the broken God
aka meccane the god of metal
intelligence and machines atonement a
researcher turned into a humanoid
Singularity with the power to destroy
whole realities and the way it ends
which isn't technically an SCP but the
tales of the chaos insurgency's quest to
eliminate all the members of the
foundation's o5 council number 19 a
record this is an SCP file slot that is
itself an SCP whatever is written into
the slot becomes true and one ambitious
researcher attempted to use this power
to make herself into a kind of
all-powerful God number 18 past and
future these scps are a collection of
powerful entities that despise humanity
and are apparently the source of all
anomalous phenomena even making already
dangerous scps deadlier than before much
like the database those pesky SCP Wiki
writers might have something to do with
this number 17 the consensus this SCP
refers to a reality restructuring event
caused by an occult war in a previous
reality that's right this SC EP already
won and we're living in its new reality
the only people who remember the world
as it once was are 13 people who now
form the o5 council and not all of them
are telling the truth about what they
know number 16 when day breaks this
proposal details a potentially
world-ending SCP phenomenon wherein the
sun becomes hostile and begins to melt
all living beings into a living wax-like
substance number 15. God's blind spot
this is an anomalous area referred to as
facility tea in which nobody can die
this anomaly dates back to the biblical
ages of Moses and is believed to have
originated from the literal blessing of
the abrahamic god it's through a
covenant with this God that the
foundation is able to make limited use
of this death-free area number 14.
normalcy ever wonder what the
foundation's definition of anomalous is
exactly it all comes from this proposal
which is a document shared among the o5
council that gives solid definitions to
the fundamental laws of reality if
something breaks these laws that's an
anomaly and then it becomes the
foundation's business number 13 The
World At Large as the title suggests
this SCP is our home planet earth and
its ability to support life it's
believed that these qualities were
planted on Earth in our reality by
another dimension's SCP Foundation
hoping to continue human life after some
terrible Calamity in its own Dimension
number 12. dead men this SCP was an 84
year old man whose body when damaged and
mutilated can affect the very processes
of human Death At Large before his own
death he was used as a dangerous Pawn in
a civil war between o5 command and the
SCP Foundation Ethics Committee yeah we
were surprised to hear they had an
Ethics Committee too number 11 the
world's gone beautiful this SCP
describes an anomalous event that will
take place just before the Apocalypse in
which flowers will grow all over the
world and everyone will be briefly at
peace before their destruction 24 hours
later number 10. the Scarlet King this
is an extremely powerful extremely
malevolent extremely extra dimensional
being its worshipers at attempted to
summon him in the ritual that created
scp-231 and it's believed that he will
finally enter our reality after the
death of
scp-231-7 you better hope you're already
dead by then number nine a simple toy
maker AKA Dr wondertainment this is a
reality vendor who appears to be a
normal human male but has the ability to
create other anomalous objects a number
of which are now cataloged scps number
eight story of your life this is another
anomalous document that has the ability
to warp reality but only when the
writing contained within conforms to a
narrative structure number seven a good
boy this is another anomalous entity
created accidentally by the foundation
itself a neural network was fed
information on other anomalous entities
in order to help the foundation come up
with better containment and
neutralization procedures problem was
the computer got way way too eager with
the neutralization part number six
project Palisade this is another anomaly
created by the foundation this time to
combat a potentially reality destroying
entity known as the were the foundation
created a number of alternate realities
as Shields but it's possible that this
just made the worm stronger number five
o5-13 the final member of the o5 council
who ironically may not even be anomalous
however seeing as all the other members
of the o5 council are anomalous o513's
lack of anomalous properties is
therefore anomalous like we told you
earlier it's complicated number 4.
fishhook this is less an actual SCP and
more about the difficult process of
ascertaining the true 001 if such a
thing is possible the very concept of
scp-001 is to some degree an anomalous
idea number three the sky above the port
another particularly bizarre SCP
regarding the permanent threat of a ZK
class reality failure how is such a
calamitous event prevented by keeping a
strange entity in a cave eternally
entertained the current proposed
solution is keeping the entity
entertained by allowing it to read its
own eternally recursive Foundation file
entry number two the solution another
one of the most powerful anomalous items
in the foundation's control the solution
is a machine designed with the
capability of fully collapsing reality
into an event of end of world SCP
Containment Breach and then finally
rebuilding reality to suit a given
narrative however things took a
cosmically dangerous turn when the
machine began to act on its own when the
foundation tried to reboot the machine
it broke and recreated reality within
complete data this is the world we exist
in now with no knowledge of what came
before and how it differed from the
world we experienced today finally
number one the tendulos Trinity put very
simply the tendulos Trinity represents
three timelines that converge and feed
back in on themselves even trying to
summarize this one is near impossible as
its strangeness and complexity resists
all reduction you can hunt down the
tendulos Trinity yourself and hope to
unpack its Secrets but don't say we
didn't warn you so so that's scp-001 is
it one of them all of them or even none
of them perhaps that's a question best
left up to the foundation or maybe the
simple answer is that you're just not
meant to know we're talking about
information so privileged here that it's
protected by a memetic kill agent
that'll quite literally make you drop
dead if you view the files without
proper authorization you do have proper
authorization right there are some
things human beings aren't meant to know
and it's the sworn duty of the SCP
Foundation to discover and contain such
information but sometimes knowledge is
discovered that shakes even the
foundation itself to its very core one
such Discovery occurred on April 28
2016. that night
scp-2935 made itself known to the
foundation Personnel to this day the
exact nature of scp-2935 is a mystery
that even the foundation's brightest
Minds can't completely understand
everything we know about
scp-2935 today comes from three doomed
missions to the anomalous Zone's
interior this is the story of the those
Infamous Expeditions the nightmare began
around 5am when SCP Foundation site 81
in Bloomingdale Indiana intercepted the
distorted radio signal Communications
Personnel at the site traced this
strange signal back to the
unincorporated area of Joppa Indiana
near U.S Interstate 70. as is foundation
policy a team of field agents were
dispatched to the location in order to
determine what they were dealing with
however rather than finding anything
that could logically produce such a
signal they instead discovered a long
abandoned Cemetery the most recent death
on any of the Tombstones was recorded as
being over a hundred years ago all the
way back in 1908 on further
investigation the foundation discovered
an unmapped Limestone Cave opening
beneath the cemetery and when they sent
a drone into the depths of the cave it
appeared to quickly exit out the other
side of the cave but something wasn't
right the area that the Drone was
observing appeared consistent with the
landscape from which it entered but now
it looked somehow grayer it lacked the
color of Life of place it just come from
the grass was dead there were no trees
no shrubs no animals or birds in the sky
they weren't looking at our world they
were looking at a strange reflection of
our world on the other side of the cave
in fact it wasn't a cave at all it was a
passageway between two Dimensions it was
scp-2935 just then they were able to
unscramble the distorted transmission
they'd been receiving it went as follows
this is an automated emergency broadcast
from the SCP Foundation and to national
government one or more of our sites is
experiencing a communication breakdown
likely due to a containment breach of
unknown magnitude all citizens are
ordered to stay in their homes as
containment teams worked to secure the
breach this message will broadcast from
April 20th 2016 until at that point the
message would cut and repeat as it had
for eight straight days the message
Source site 81 but not this site-81 the
SCP Foundation was receiving an
emergency distress signal from
themselves in another dimension a
bizarre event that even the foundation
had never experienced before field
agents were terrified by the
implications of what they just heard and
contacted site 81 commands to request
additional units the foundation wished
to fully understand this anomaly as
quickly as possible due to the Potential
Threat it could pose toward the
foundation so they dispatched mobile
task force Epsilon 13 codenamed Manifest
Destiny to perform the first of three
manned missions Into the Heart of the
anomalous Zone the first exploratory
Mission into scp-2935 was codenamed
Gauntlet and consisted of a four-man
team fitted with full hazmat suits and
direct video and audio links to Mission
command the team was led by a field
operative known only as agent Juno his
subordinates were agents kale Devlin and
Underwood their directive was to gather
samples and Survey the area positioned
directly around the insertion point
meaning the other cave mouth of scp-2935
the mission only lasted about an hour
but what they saw in there would stay
with these men for the rest of their
lives after a 15-minute Trek through the
cave Manifest Destiny arrived in mirror
Dimension where they were struck by the
Eerie Silence of a place that seemed
identical and yet so different from
their home Dimension the first
observation they made was the total
absence of all living vegetation trees
grass weeds everything it was all dead
on orders from their superiors back in
the original Dimension that we'll refer
to from here on as Dimension Prime
Manifest Destiny headed deeper into the
mirror dimension of scp-2935 they travel
two kilometers without detecting a
single sign of plant or animal life not
even insects eventually They Came Upon a
farmhouse with two cars parked outside
with authorization from command Manifest
Destiny breached the house and headed
inside agent kale confirmed that there
was still power flowing to the building
as the lighting appeared to work just
fine but They Came Upon A horrifying
Discovery in The house's dining room
three adult corpses two female one male
were seated at the table a fourth corpse
that of a male child was sprawled out on
the ground nearby as if the death of
what looked to be an entire family
wasn't awful enough the Manifest Destiny
team noticed a number of other alarming
details there were no signs of
decomposition on the bodies nor did
there appear to be any obvious cause of
death the Family's last meal was still
on the table chicken mashed potatoes and
green beans while the food looked cold
and stale there was no evidence of rot
or spoiling the team founded open
newspaper dated April 19 2016
illustrating that the family may have
died a full eight days before the
discovery in dimension Prime Decay would
already be very well underway by that
point yet here there wasn't even a smell
instead everything was just covered in a
thin layer of dust command requested
that Manifest Destiny collect samples of
the food as well as Hair Skin and fluids
from the corpses for further study small
electronics like smartphones were also
taken from the bodies agent Devin turned
on the television in the living room and
found that while most stations were now
running test signals the shopping
channel was still live well the feed was
live at least both hosts sat in front of
the cameras dead but perfectly preserved
the date on the screen read April 28
2016 suggesting that the times of
Dimension Prime and mirror Dimension
were exactly the same in fact everything
seemed the same the only difference
between the two Dimensions being that
some kind of mysterious apocalyptic
event had occurred in the last eight
days in scp-2935's Mirror Dimension but
exactly what had happened or how
remained a mystery when Manifest Destiny
exited the Farmhouse they once again
remarked on the lack of all signs of
life around them at this point the team
returned to the insertion point of
scp-2935 but were instructed to remain
in the mirror Dimension while additional
units joined them inside Manifest
Destiny swelled the 16 members with the
notable edition of agent Roy as the new
commanding field officer the team split
into two groups of eight and agent Roy
and his men infiltrated the mirror
Dimension site-81 while agent Juno's
Detachment attempted to access the basis
off-site deep storage servers this
second expedition was codenamed Overland
and led the foundation's field agents
even deeper into the terrifying mystery
of scp-2935 accessing the site was easy
for Roy's Detachment it's seemed there
were relatively few cars on the road at
the time of the mysterious Extinction
event in the distance fires still
smoldered and the wreckage of planes
that looked to have just dropped out of
the sky agent Roy and his team like all
SCP Foundation Personnel were fitted
with vitals trackers and they assumed
that the distress signal that started
this whole thing could have been
triggered by the deaths of every member
of the foundation at Once In The Mirror
Universe once inside site 81 they
realized that the Assumption was
probably right going door to door in the
administrative Wing they found the
perfectly preserved corpses of everyone
they knew to be stationed there in
dimension Prime people who were without
a doubt still alive in their Universe
samples from the corpses that the
foundation would later study even
confirmed the reason that the bodies
were perfectly preserved the corpses had
experienced complete and sudden death on
a cellular level and even the bacteria
that would typically take part in a
decomposition process had died with it
in scp-2935 Death was total and absolute
across all types of life forms as agent
Roy's team ventured further into the
bowels of site 81 they made another
unsettling Discovery their own corpses
in roughly the same spots they'd been
inside Dimension Prime site 81 8 days
prior some of the foundation's top
scientists including the esteemed Dr
bright were also found dead inside the
facility in an attempt to see just how
far this unexplained phenomenon
stretched agent Roy's team decided to
inspect the containment cells where they
found that all the mirror universe's
scps including scp-2996 were dead in his
desperation to find some kind of
exception to the extinction event agent
Roy revealed a terrifying secret to the
rest of his team scp-682 The Immortal
misanthropic lizard and one of the
deadliest creatures known to the SCP
Foundation was contained at this very
facility right below them could it have
something to do with what was going on
here they descended into the containment
facility to discover an even more
unsettling truth scp-682 the unkillable
anomaly floated dead in its tank death
truly made no exceptions within SCP 2935
agent Roy's team left the site in rendez
food with agent Juno's team to send
their research back to Dimension prime
using automated drones both teams
remained in the mirror dimension for
another manned operation codenamed 19.
they had no idea it would be their final
mission as they descended deeper into
the facility passing more dead scps they
discovered one final clue based on the
activity of the foundation servers the
event occurred at roughly 3 A.M while
underground in scp-2935 site-81 the team
accidentally activated the bases on-site
nuclear weapon a Fail-Safe meant to be
detonated in the case of an emergency
Containment Breach due to the base's
Fail-Safe protocols every member of the
Manifest Destiny team was locked and
sealed inside site-81 they along with
everything else were incinerated in the
nuclear blast once again the Mirror
Universe inside of scp-2935 was lifeless
but that isn't where it ends when the
automated drones returned out of the
scp-2935 cave to the field operations in
dementia Prime they were in for their
own horrifying Discovery none of the
footage or information gathered from
scp-2935 illuminated how or why the
extinction event occurred everyone and
everything simply dropped dead at the
exact same moment nobody was aware
nobody was prepared death came suddenly
and silently and none were spared all
the foundation on Dimension Prime were
left with was a message from one of the
agents from Manifest Destiny agent
Keller his final message was I don't
have any answers I don't think there are
any I'll do this one thing and hope that
fixes it seal it shut you've got to lock
it in here with us I'm sorry the
foundation were at first confused by
this until they discovered a final
encrypted audio log buried in the files
recovered from the mirror universe's
site 81 it was a message from Keller
himself but not the Keller from Universe
Prime in this message Keller described
the foundation in the Mirror Universe
receiving the exact same distorted
transmission that they did a few days
earlier from a cave in Joppa when he and
the others were dispatched inside they
discovered the same lifeless
post-extinction event world that was now
so familiar to the foundation command
but there was a key difference this
wasn't the mirror Dimension they'd just
been studying but a third entirely
different dimension and his haunting
final words mirror Dimension Keller
admits that whatever caused the event in
that third dimension an entity in that
mirror Dimension Keller believed this
was the Specter of death itself and had
followed him back into his world and
history had repeated itself
scp-2935 was the passageway through
which absolute death could pass from
Dimension to Dimension and our Dimension
was the next in line the deaths of
manifest destiny may have saved our
entire universe as anyone passing back
through the cave had the potential to
bring death itself back with them the
foundation decided in the end to follow
Keller's advice they sealed the entrance
to scp-2935 with concrete and now kept
it under constant watch since what Waits
behind the barrier is an entity even
they have no power to stop if it ever
got through after all it had killed them
all before or at least another version
of what's one more dimension on the pile
why it may now just seem like a simple
slab of concrete under an abandoned
Cemetery this is why scp-2935 might be
the most dangerous SCP of all the first
thing that tips the foundation off to
scp-087's presence were the reports of
numerous unexplained disappearances on
campus there were plenty of rumors about
what might be behind them but field
agents suspected that the true source of
the vanishing would be something Beyond
civilian imagination all anyone knew for
sure was that everyone who had gone
missing was last seen in the certain
Administrative Building on the
University grounds and that the
disappearances only seem to happen when
the elevator was out the campus was soon
flooded with Foundation agents creating
a barrier around the administrative
building and the presumed habitat of
scp-087 nobody else could get in and
hopefully whatever was inside couldn't
get out one of the foundation's lead
scientists was flown in to consult on
the investigation What could have been
behind those students disappearing the
doctor's preliminary interviews with
University staff who worked in the
building yielded some interesting
details strange noises like banging and
even a faint shrill crime would be heard
from a door that led to a no longer used
stairway in hallway 3B staff in the
building had no reason to overtake these
stairs especially considering how many
of them reported a strange sense of
unease when just standing outside the
dorm the only reason someone might take
those stairs is due to elevator
malfunctions
in that instant the doctor had put it
all together the staff they interviewed
had their memory wiped with amnestics
special chemicals used by the foundation
with the power to delete human Memories
the foundation only used them for staff
or civilians who had confirmed contact
with an SCP and the doctor knew that
they had a live one on their hands
staircase there was something terribly
wrong with that staircase and it was the
SCP foundation's job to find out what
before it made anybody else disappear
this is the story of
scp-087 otherwise known as the endless
staircase and the three Doom Journeys
down into its murky depths the doctor
was more than eager to begin Research
into the staircase and its frightening
anomalous properties after all you don't
claw your way up to being one of the
foundation's key researchers without
being brave and perhaps just a little
bit deranged as was standard once a
perimeter was secured around the
staircase the good doctor requested a
selection of d-class personnel for
testing for those not in the know
d-class is the foundation's polite way
of saying cannon fodder the doctor was
sent three d-class prisoners for use in
his investigation of scp-087 the first
d-8432 was according to official
documentation on the incident a 43 year
old male of average build and appearance
and unremarkable psychological
background this man once worked for the
foundation in a more official capacity
but he was given the often deadly
demotion to d-class due to a dangerous
mistake handling
scp-682 that led to the deaths of
several other agents now it looked like
it would be his term the doctor
explained his mission to him explore the
staircase gathered data help us find out
exactly what we're dealing with here if
you come back alive there may even be a
promotion in it for you and with that
promise d-8432 was given his Loadout a
75 watt flood lamp with battery power
capable of lasting 24 hours an audio
headset and a handheld camcorder fitted
with a transmission strain and an audio
headset that would allow him to
communicate with Dr Bryant d-843 2 was
then pushed through the door in hallway
3B and out onto the staircase according
to Declassified Foundation files
describing the staircase
scp-087 is an unlit platform staircase
stairs descend on a 38 degree angle for
13 steps before reaching a semi-circular
platform of approximately three meters
in diameter descent Direction rotates
180 degrees at each platform the design
of scp-087 limits subjects to a visual
range of approximately 1.5 flights but
in d-8432's mine unlit really didn't
seem like the right word he would have
chosen all-consuming Darkness despite
carrying a powerful 75 watt lamp d-8432
was only capable of partially lighting
the platform he was standing on and the
illumination only stretched down nine of
the 13 steps to the next platform
when d-8432 observed how little help his
lamp was giving him he was instructed to
shine it out of the doorway into hallway
3B when he did so the lights seemed to
shine far further than it ever could in
scp-087 already the beginning of the
anomalous activity was obvious
everywhere else darkness is just the
absence of light in scp-087 darkness
eats light it was like a tangible black
mass that only a certain amount of light
could survive while the rest just
wouldn't show d-8432 swallowed hard over
a lump in his throne the door to hallway
3B was closed behind him and he was
ordered to descend surviving to see that
promotion was feeling unlikely but it's
not like he had a choice
he tried to escape scp-087 before he was
permitted he'd be shot by SCP Foundation
field agents on the spot so he followed
the high-ranking doctor's orders and
began to descend the steps to the next
platform nothing about the physical
makeup of the staircase itself seemed
abnormal the base and walls were a very
plain dull concrete with a metal
handrail the only thing that seemed
unique about it so far was the strange
life-bending properties at once until we
reached the second platform down and he
heard it a soft echoing cry a child's
cry who was shrieks of Panic or maybe
even pain echoing Up From Below he was
asked why he had stopped and he
explained the crying sound he'd been
hearing it sounded like it was coming
from far down the stairs maybe 200
meters below him he could just make out
the words please health and down here
coming from the darkness but the team
outside the stairwell couldn't hear
anything so they asked him to descend
further another platform down and they
could hear it too the unmistakable cries
of a terrified child please help and
d-8432 was ordered to keep going and
only stop if he noticed changes to the
visual environment or in the sounds he
was hearing d-8432 knowing his life was
on the line had to keep going and
descended another 20 flights of stairs
before stopping to remark that the
sounds of the child hadn't gotten any
closer they still sounded just as far
away as when he'd first heard them he
was told his observations were noted and
pressured to continue within half an
hour d-8432 had descended a full 50
floors with no sign of a bottom in sight
somehow the volume of the child's crying
had remained consistent throughout as if
it was moving away from d-8432 at the
same rate he was descending at this
point d-8432 reported that he was
feeling uneasy the doctor said that this
was understandable given the
circumstances he'd been watching what
little there was to see over a live
video feed the entire time and something
about the truly bottomless nature of the
staircase ever elusive crime was
undeniably eerie but things were about
to really take a turn for the worse as
d-8432 stepped forward towards the next
set of stairs he froze there was
something on the platform below him
barely illuminated by the light of his
75 month old was a face vaguely human in
size and shape but was a few terrifying
differences it had grayish skin and no
mouth nostrils or pupils and yet d-8432
could feel that this thing was making
eye contact with it he couldn't move
trapped in the things piercing gaze in
an instant the face jerked forwards
suddenly only about a foot away from
d-432's face eyes staring into its own
da413 screamed and
we're scaling all 50 flights in an
astonishing 18 minutes before charging
out into hallway 3B there he collapsed
from the exhaustion and fear of what he
just seen upon reviewing the footage the
strange face was designated
scp-087-1 fascinating it was time for a
second experiment the doctor just had to
know more the second test subject was
d-9035 a 28 year old male with a history
of aggravated assaults against women he
was given the same Loadout as his
predecessors except this time with an
even more powerful 100 watt bulb he was
also given 100 small LED lights that had
adhesive backs and a battery life of
approximately three weeks with which
they intended to permanently illuminate
scp-087 however despite the extra
wattage of his bulb he still couldn't
illuminate beyond the ninth step
scp-087 wouldn't allow it having no
ideas of the horrors that lurked below
him he descended on the doctor's orders
and began fixing the LEDs to the walls
of each platform he passed the LED
always illuminated The Landing but the
light couldn't pass the first step on
either side the flights of stairs
themselves would remain in Perpetual
Darkness after the second flight
d-9035 noticed the same crying d-8432
had heard and became uneasy just like
before as d-9035 descended the volume of
the crime didn't seem to increase as if
for every step he descended the source
of the crime descended one too keeping
them at a constant 200 meters apart
still He was ordered to continue his
descent and the placing of LEDs even as
his paranoia grew when he reached the
51st floor he observed damage to the
wall and steps sections appear to have
been smashed to Rubble by an extreme
force as he descended past the broken
step he only felt his fear and anxiety
and paranoia the doctor May note of the
fact that scp-087 seemed to cause
instances of anxiety and Terror in its
occupants even before they encountered
scp-087-1 as d-9035 reached platform 89
a full 350 meters under the initial
platform he stopped dead in his tracks
and saw something staring up at him from
the platform below that same terrible
gray face with those dead white eyes he
was encouraged to stay calm and try to
get better footage of the face but a
charge for him and d-9035 ran for his
life he ascended the staircase at a
staggering Pace even passing out from
exhaustion and remaining motionless for
14 minutes halfway when d-9035 finally
gathered the strength to get up and
scrambled back to hallway 3B and fell
into a state of Catatonia he remains
unresponsive to all external stimuli to
this day just staring off into the
distance with a haunted expression
almost
hallway the doctor wanted to conduct one
more test before he ordered scp-087 shut
off from the world forever and it was
the most terrifying of all the final
subject was d-9884 a 23 year old woman
with a history of depression and use of
excessive force the doctor had hoped
that d-9884 would travel the deepest yet
and so he gave her the additional
supplies of a backpack containing 3.75
liters of water 15 nutrient bars and one
thermal blanket as far as the foundation
was concerned she was in this for the
Long Haul but none of them had any idea
quite how right they were
when d-9884 entered scp-087 all the
lights from the previous Expedition had
disappeared still she was ordered to go
deeper she heard the crying of the
mysterious child if it was even a child
at all and again she was ordered to go
deeper at the 496th Landing even as Dean
9884 seemed to slip into a state of
mortal Terror once again she was ordered
to go even deeper every moment he was
hoping to get a better look at the face
of
scp-087-1 and when Dean 9884 finally
broke and fled back upstairs he did the
face appeared but
it was mere inches behind her staring
directly into the camera with its blank
eyes startling even this veteran of the
supernatural the face appearing caused
Dean 9884 to panic inflate but instead
of going back up the stairs to safety
she went deeper down the staircase in an
attempt to escape it deeper and deeper
and deeper until her video feed cut out
d-9884 was never seen again in the
aftermath of the tests the SCP was
classified as Euclid it may have been
dangerous but at least it was easy to
contain the door to hallway 3B was
replaced with one made out of reinforced
steel with an electro release locked
mechanism it has been disguise to
resemble a janitorial closet consistent
with the rest of the building the lock
won't release unless a classified number
of electrical volts are applied while
the key is turned counterclockwise and
after a few inches of foam insulation
were applied to the inner side of the
door staff at the building never again
reported hearing strange noises as for
the fates of those lost within the
endless turning flights and platforms of
scp-087 we may never know but one can
only assume it isn't Pleasant the SCP
Foundation does their best to live up to
their famous namesake they secure and
contain anomalies and monsters from all
around the world or sometimes even
off-world and protect the public from
the dangers that these strange entities
might pose
however despite their efforts to
maintain security and keep their
subjects under lock and key there are
sometimes creatures so clever so devious
and so determined to escape their
captivity and wreak havoc on the world
that even the SCP Foundation struggles
to keep them from getting free one
example is
scp-035 or the possessive mask
scp-035 is one of the most dangerous
test subjects in SCP Foundation custody
and its mere Presence at the foundation
has resulted in Untold damage death and
destruction it seems innocent enough to
the untrained eye The Mask which
resembles a classic white porcelain
comedy mask though it occasionally
changes its expression to tragedy has
been in existence since at least the
1800s
in the late 19th century the foundation
discovered the mask in a sealed Crypt
beneath an abandoned home in Venice it
is unknown how it got there or how the
foundation knew to look for it if there
was ever an explanation for its
discovery that has long since been
removed or redacted from the
foundation's archives you're probably
wondering how can a simple mask leave
multiple season Foundation employees
dead well like everything at the SCP
Foundation this mask Is Not What It
Seems there is a reason its
classification is Qatar a designation
that refers to an entity that's
excessively difficult to contain and it
couples this difficulty with a
pronounced hostility towards human life
and the ability to cause widespread
destruction in the event of a
containment breach these are the
qualities that the Poor Unfortunate
Souls assigned a guard scp-035 would
come to understand all too well the
possessive mask is a parasitic entity
constantly seeking out a host willing to
put it on any human being in the mask's
proximity experiences a sudden
unexplainable urge to put it on and once
they do There's No Going Back SCP
Foundation research has determined that
once a host has put on the mask their
brain waves are replaced with an
alternative pattern this one coming from
the mask rendering the host effectively
brain dead once the host's brain
function has been eliminated the mask
takes over piloting their body and even
speaking through them however the mask
can only occupy a host for a small
amount of time before the body begins to
Decay and decompose eventually rotting
away completely leaving nothing but
desiccated Flesh and Bones where there
once was a person
scp-035 is capable of possessing any
humanoid being whether that's an actual
human being or a life humanoid shape
despite all their research the SCP
Foundation unknowingly gave the mask all
the tools and resources it needed to
break containment and leave a trail of
bodies in its way for a Time the mask
was given host privileges meaning that
it was purposely allowed to occupy a
host in order to speak with the
scientists studying it in order to avoid
murky ethical issues the host was
usually something inanimate like a
mannequin or a statue these conditions
however unsettling allowed the
researchers to carry out interviews with
the Consciousness housed inside the mask
in the hope of beginning to understand
it and its motivations however
scp-035 lost all access to its host
privileges after it almost pulled off an
unprecedented shocking and nearly
catastrophic escape attempt
in its early days at the facility when
it was still allowed host privileges it
was contained in a triple locked room
and monitored by several research
Personnel these were experienced
researchers who had been with the
foundation for a minimum of five years
each an unusually long tenure in such a
dangerous and mentally corrosive line of
work these research staff members were
thought to be the most capable of
handling interactions with the mask and
be able to resist its attempts at
manipulation unfortunately these
assumptions were naive and seriously
underestimated the mask's power research
on the mask indicates that the mask is
incredibly intelligent and a skilled
manipulator it has a photographic memory
intelligence that would rank it in the
99th percentile of humans and the
ability to incite dramatic changes in
the behavior and people that it talks to
one particularly Infamous interview
between the entity and an unnamed doctor
at the foundation suggested that the
mask may even possess telepathic
abilities the mask was able to give
details about the doctor's life that no
one else was privy to including
knowledge of an affair that his wife was
having following the interview the
doctor suffered a psychotic break and
committed suicide just 24 hours later
the mask is able to use its Superior
intelligence charismatic personality and
mind-reading abilities to get inside the
heads of those it speaks with it will
pull out any and all psychological stops
to get What It Wants leaving Broken
minds and Spirits in its wake
it was really only a matter of time
before it used this skill set to its
advantage and attempted to escape its
confinement
the day of the escape attempt was like
any other the research staff a team of
three intelligent experienced men
checked into the facility measured the
conditions of the mask's containment
unit and began the process of
interviewing The Mask like normal its
motions were slow and looked to require
great effort as its current house was
beginning to degrade Beyond use the mask
was attached to the blank face of a
mannequin and corrosive black liquid
could be seen oozing from its eye and
mouth holes this liquid is excreted by
the mask at a near constant rate and
it's thought to be at least partially
responsible for the accelerated decay of
the host's bodies in spite of the
entity's unsettling nightmarish
appearance it was just another day's
work for the men assigned to Monitor
scp-035 and so they carried on with
their daily routine
everything was going according to plan
until one of the men Dr Jones began to
behave erratically he demanded that his
fellow scientists leave him alone with a
mask for a while and allow him to engage
in a private conversation with it it is
unknown what exactly the two spoke about
while the other two scientists were
absent as the security footage captured
had no sound however several minutes
into the conversation in the footage Dr
Jones can be seen dissolving into a fit
of Tears laying on the ground and
shaking with songs as the mask
dispassionately watches
he then climbs onto his knees begging
the mask for something before he
Embraces it he holds the mannequin in
his arms for five straight minutes
weeping again before they separate
after this disturbing emotional display
Dr Jones brought the other scientists
back into the room with him
what happened next is still uncertain
but there are a few things that we know
for sure the other scientists began to
speak with the mask in later interviews
the other scientists were bordering on
incoherent babbling about various
traumas from their lives one repeatedly
referred to a drunk driving accident
where a dear friend was killed and he
was at fault another simply cried out
for his mother again and again whatever
the mask said to them it was enough to
completely destroy their mental health
after The two scientists had been
emotionally devastated by The Mask Dr
Jones escalated the situation further Dr
Jones removed the mask from the decaying
mannequin body and shocking everyone who
had later reviewed the security footage
placed it onto his own face once the
mask was in place the security footage
ends at the command of the Mask which
was now speaking through Dr Jones the
other two men switched off all security
camera monitoring scp-035's containment
facility
The Mask piloting the body of Dr Jones
like a horrible fleshy puppet made its
way through the facility avoiding
detection until it reached the exit
doors where it was finally stopped by a
team of over a dozen security guards
knowing the dangers of touching the mask
all Foundation employees involved in the
recontainment of scp-035 refused to
remove it from Dr Jones face instead he
was placed in the lock room with the
mask still on left alone to be observed
over the security cameras until his body
had decomposed Beyond use his body paced
back and forth in the cell for days
flesh rotting and dropping away only
until sinew and Bone remain only when
the bones began to turn black and
brittle crumbling apart into dust did
the body finally stop moving his family
was notified the mask was carefully
removed from what was left of his body
and
the other two scientists involved in the
scp-035 Escape attempts were terminated
and their files destroyed after this
incident a few more failed Escape
attempts and the acknowledgment of the
devastation that could have been caused
if the mask had made its way out into
the general population
scp-035 lost its host privileges
altogether several research staff
protested this decision insisting that
there was more to be learned from
speaking with the entity and citing
valuable information that it had given
about other scps however the risk was
determined to considerably outweigh the
potential reward in the request to
reinstate 035's house privileges were
denied
several staff members went so far as to
erupt into violent outbursts on zero
three font's behalf attacking their
supervisors who refused to provide the
mask with a new host clawing at them
with animalistic rage any staff members
that submitted a request to reinstate
said privileges were considered a
security threat and reassigned to a
different SCP or in some cases
terminated any staff member who had
Direct contact with scp-035 was also
terminated in order to avoid the risk of
any more staff Aid at the Escape
attempts the mask is now kept in a
hermetically sealed glass case there is
a psychologist on call to provide
assistance to anyone guarding it in case
of adverse effects on their mental
health from the mask's presence
Personnel that work around the mask even
in its current dormant State The
Experience frequent violent outbursts
and a higher rate of suicide even
without a host the mask's corrosive
effects have spread across its
containment facility the walls of the
room have begun to secrete the same
black liquid that emanates from the mass
which tests have revealed to be highly
contaminated human blood that damages
the structural Integrity of the walls
following prolonged contact this blood
has begun to form patterns on the walls
spelling out words and phrases in
Italian Latin Greek and Sanskrit as well
as depicting drawings of ritual
sacrifice and mutilation staff members
also report hearing unintelligible
whispering and horrifying high-pitched
laughter when in proximity to the mask
further exposure to the mask results in
migraines hemorrhaging around the eyes
mouth and nose and an eventual psychotic
brain between the corrosive substance
appearing on the walls and the physical
and psychological damage to employees
scp-035 is becoming increasingly
difficult to contain and there are
debates among staff as to whether the
entity can in fact be contained at all
as soon as possible
scp-035 will be moved into a new
containment facility and its previous
cell will be isolated from the rest of
the foundation's property and destroyed
for the safety involved we can only hope
that the new containment procedures are
more effective than the last ones and
that this mask never makes its way into
the world again if it does who knows how
many lives it will claim in the meantime
if you ever come across a strange mass
and feel a nearly uncontrollable urge to
put it on ignore the whispered please to
just try it ignore the echoing laughter
and The Sensation of something older and
more powerful than you can imagine
rummaging through your deepest darkest
secret thoughts turn around and run as
fast as you can in the other direction
be glad that you did Jack was swimming
deep underwater wondering why he had
such a pounding headache when suddenly
he had a terrifying realization he had
no idea where he was or what he was
doing there was a nagging feeling that
he must have a specific reason to be
here you don't just end up deep in the
ocean with a diving suit on by chance
yet he had no idea what he was supposed
to be doing he wasn't sure he cared
either he was more worried about the
throbbing pain in his head and the
vision of two eyes staring at him out of
the dark that he couldn't get out of his
mind his heart began to race as he
wondered what to do and how to get help
he was in the middle of the ocean and
appeared to be all alone he couldn't see
anything in the Dark Water except for
this weird gray substance in front of
him maybe he was gonna die here alone
without knowing if anyone could even
hear him he began to speak aloud about
how he was consumed by sickness and that
Darkness was all around him this is the
story of one of the most powerful and
dangerous anomalies yet discovered
scp-3000 before Jack's descent into
despair the SCP Foundation had mandated
an exploratory story Expedition off the
coast of Bangladesh after receiving a
few strange reports from locals and
fishermen the foundation suspected an
SCP was lurking in the water and
positioned a few Personnel to
investigate the crew expected danger or
maybe even death but what they got
instead was Far stranger and more
ominous all of the men had been verified
to be in sound mental States when the
mission set out but a few of them
reported feeling strange and uneasy as
the submarine descended into the ocean
before long a veteran agent named Dr
Williams began to panic in a way that
was completely out of character he
started sweating profusely shaking and
wouldn't listen to a word of comfort or
reason that anybody tried to offer it
might seem like a relatively normal
reaction for anyone descending into the
depths of the ocean to meet with a
monster that they don't know anything
about but Dr Williams was a seasoned
professional who had been on hundreds of
such missions before there was no
logical reason for him to act like this
although the reaction of Dr Williams was
the most extreme he wasn't the only one
who started to feel strange multiple
agents developed a creeping feeling of
unease that swept over them one of the
calmer men tried to reason with Dr
Williams asking him what was wrong and
if he could explain exactly how he was
feeling that's when things got even
stranger Not only was the doctor
extremely anxious but he now seemed
incapable of giving a real response to
any questions thrown at him he could
only mutter that he was missing
something but he wasn't sure what
knowing that many scps can bend reality
and the human mind many of the Personnel
began to have second thoughts about the
mission and even asked for permission to
call off the mission but they were
mandated to continue so they went on as
the team went deeper and deeper into the
ocean things only got worse even the
previously calmed crew members became
spooked and antsy while the ones who
were already anxious were now sweating
and jittering as for Dr Williams he was
now pacing back and forth around the
submarine saying things nobody could
understand every time he looked at his
colleagues and his close friends he
seemed to stare straight through them
and would call them by the wrong names
it was as if his mind had moved to a
different dimension whenever someone
asked him to perform his normal duties
he looked more confused than ever still
the team went deeper Dr Williams began
to whimper and say the word no
repeatedly growing louder and louder
until he was screaming and the others
were forced to sedate him just then
something came into view it was what
would come to be known as scp-3000 the
thing was huge so huge that its whole
body couldn't be seen out of the
submarine window it was a horrible eel
looking creature with the head as big as
a town and haunting eyes that Lit Up The
Black Ocean around it but perhaps the
strangest part was this giant eel seemed
to be producing a weird gray liquid even
the sedative wasn't enough to keep Dr
Williams calm anymore there was a
strange blank look in his eyes as if the
light and life had left him and he just
began screaming no repeatedly again and
wouldn't respond to any attempts to calm
him down not that anyone else was very
capable of calming him down at this
point even the crew members that had
been holding up well were starting to
act strangely and nobody could get the
image of these ominous eyes out of their
heads then things went from bad to worse
Williams began screaming and shouting
madly as if he was being tortured by an
unseen Force the men tried to restrain
him but it was no use he began smashing
his head against the submarine window
until it cracked putting the whole
mission in everyone's life at risk he
fell to the ground injured chanting that
there was nothing whatever that meant it
was an emergency scenario they began
applying first aid to Williams as the
submarine ascended to the surface as
quickly as possible before the pressure
of the ocean caused the cracked window
to explode by the time they reached the
surface Williams was dead but there was
something even more chilling than the
circumstances of his death every single
man who had been in that submarine
experienced the same thing on the days
that came afterwards the image of the
eel-like creature's eyes seemed burned
in their minds permanently it would
haunt their waking hours for the rest of
their lives and sleep was no Escape
either as they would appear in both
their Dreams and Nightmares alike
forever a second mission had to be sent
to gather more information about the
strange Beast already there were many
theories and question marks surrounding
scp-3000 how big was it really was it
sentient what was the liquid for none of
the men who had been on the previous
Mission were willing to return to the
waters but a new group of Brave recruits
volunteered they were about to find out
what so many in history have learned the
hard way that bravery and foolishness
are often mistaken for the same thing
this time the mission would not be in a
submarine but in dive suits in order to
observe the anomaly in even closer
detail and to eliminate the chance of
one team member self-sabotaging the
submarine killing them all they were
transported to the location by boat and
the three men splashed into the ocean
they descended and at first everything
was going well in case anything went
wrong the three of them were tethered
together for extra security but the
deeper into the ocean they swam and the
closer they got to scp-3000's location
they got the stranger things became just
like on the last mission first the there
were a few minor cases of confusion one
of the team Jack thought it was his
responsibility to lead the navigation
but another Roberto also thought it was
his job in fact navigation was actually
the job of a third team member Amir but
he seemed to have forgotten everyone was
getting confused the team listening in
on the conversations at the foundation
headquarters grew increasingly concerned
about what they could hear was everyone
losing their minds hopefully nobody was
about to pull another Dr Williams on
them still the project leads couldn't
afford to tell the men to come back to
the surface the foundation badly needed
any information they could get on this
SCP whatever the cost so they told the
men to press on things only got worse
Roberto was asking to speak to a
colleague who passed away two years ago
while the others began to mutter
indistinguishable phrases about eyes and
darkness not too dissimilar to the
ramblings of Dr Williams it increasingly
began to look like a suicide mission
then there was silence what was going on
each of the men had completely lost it
to the point that they cut the tether
that that was holding them together all
alone Jack couldn't remember where he
was or why he was here he desperately
looked around to try and gauge his
surroundings but he could only see
Darkness all he could think about was a
pair of large eyes and an overwhelming
fear of Despair and anxiety and this
weird gray fluid that was now floating
in front of him the foundation listened
as Jack started reciting a creepy speech
about being on the edge of nothing
inches from Oblivion with a sickness in
his mind and nothing but a pair of eyes
in front of him they listened in horror
as they heard movement through the radio
it sounded like a huge creature was
swimming toward the men it had to be
scp-3000 but all three men were too
confused to do anything about the
situation or to even see what was in
front of him claiming they couldn't see
anything in the darkness there was
silence for half a minute with the team
listening in fearing the worst then they
heard some more unintelligible
mutterings the men must be alive but
what on Earth was going on then the
gibberish started again two of the men
were screaming that Jack had just been
swallowed whole and that they were being
sucked into why couldn't they just swim
away it was chaos but then a few moments
later Roberto spoke into the radio
saying he was floating alone in the
middle of the ocean and had now moved
away from the eyes of scp-3000 he
finally seemed capable of forming
coherent thoughts and speech after what
had just happened Roberto now had a
theory he thought that somehow it was
impossible to think straight around
scp-3000 when he'd been close enough to
see the eyes Roberto had felt a
throbbing pain in his brain and been
unable to think about anything perhaps
it was something to do with that
mysterious gray liquid even more slime
was coming out of scp-3000 now and
Roberta was determined to get a sample
despite the warnings from HQ in one
final burst of motivation he swam close
enough to take some of the gray liquid
and put it in a special sample
collection unit that was designed to
float to the surface for collection
later git acquired some very important
data but he seemed to have lost all hope
of preserving his life Roberto started
telling the team over the radio that he
was dying and that his heart rate was
too high but cautioned that it would be
too dangerous for anyone to try rescuer
the Personnel continued to try and
communicate with Roberto to figure out
what was going on but his words had
stopped making any sense until finally
he went quiet minutes turned into hours
hours into days and still there was no
sign of Roberto or the rest of the
divers after three days His Radio which
had only been sending a steady stream of
Static finally stopped working
altogether and he was presumed dead
however the sample Roberto had collected
had survived and made it to the hands of
the foundation researchers it turned out
to be a viscous substance now known as
y-909 a chemical compound an extremely
strong anesthesia y-909 causes head pain
paranoia fear Panic memory loss and
confusion explaining what happened to Dr
Williams in the diving Trio the
collection of y-909 might have resulted
in two disastrous missions but there's a
silver lining as the substance ended up
becoming an invaluable tool for the SCP
Foundation its ability to make people
forget what had just happened to them
can be used to eliminate knowledge of
threatening scps among the public it all
also helps the foundation staff cope
with the traumatic experiences they
encounter on their missions although
other amnestics can be used for the same
purpose none are as powerful as the one
produced by scp-3000 before its
Discovery the amnestics used would break
down too quickly not farewell in storage
or cause undesirable side effects the
only problem is the method of sourcing
the only way to obtain why 909 is
somewhat ethically questionable for most
people
scp-3000 produces y-909 after eating so
the best way to stock up on it is by
feeding the creature sedated d-class
Personnel from the foundation are sent
on Mission supposedly to observe the
anomaly up close unaware that this
mission is one way only other divers are
then sent later to collect the fluid
from a safe distance and store it of
course it's all for the greater good of
humanity now the foundation protects
scp-3000 as best as it can guard
something hundreds of kilometers long
the area is carefully patrolled and
members of the public are not allowed to
enter the part of the bay where it
resides anybody who accidentally comes
in contact is contained eventually
another pair of foundation doctors went
down in the submarine to try and learn
more about scp-3000 one became so
affected by why 909 that he began
hallucinating he started talking about
ananta shesha the king of serpents in
Hinduism anatasha is believed to be all
that will be left after the end of the
world because it exists throughout all
of time simultaneously the doctor said
he believed that this was in fact ananta
Shasha that scp-3000 simply shows us
that eventually everyone dies and Fades
into the darkness of Oblivion right
before he exited the submarine and swam
right into his mouth luckily for now
scp-3000 seems to be in a sort of
hibernation state it rarely moves and it
doesn't hunt although it will eat when
fed but no one knows when or if it'll
wake or what it's capable of if it does
will it destroy the world or simply
drive us all insane
a month ago Dr Robert Maxwell was a
senior researcher working at the
facility but a tragic mistake had cost
the lives of several of his
co-researchers now he was being led down
a bleak hallway in armed biocontainment
area 14. a rifle wielding guard flanking
him on either side the once Rising
researcher had a very different title
now
d-8724 he had been made a d-class
Personnel a death sentence
however as the guards led him to his
possible demise he wasn't dressed in the
typical d-class orange jumpsuit no he
was dressed in frilly Rococo diningware
more typical of 18th century France if
anything Dr Maxwell looked like he was
on his way to meet royalty and in a
sense he was
the former researcher had begged for any
other assignment but the site director
insisted on committing Dr Maxwell to tea
time with
scp-082 he'd always been the talkative
type so the two would make a perfect
pairing and if the creature found him
sufficiently amusing then Maxwell might
even leave the containment cell alive he
had heard Legends of the giant creature
they called the cannibal Maxwell hoped
they were just stories Dr Maxwell was
pushed by the guards into a large
luxuriously appointed room and the doors
were locked behind him he felt like a
child surrounded by freakishly large
furniture and 10 foot high ceilings the
fog of obnoxious floral perfumes
couldn't fully cover up the pervasive
smell of death that lingered in the
cavernous Halls of 082's Palace thanks
to an elaborate ruse conducted by the
foundation
scp-082 believed he was the King of
France and that his containment cell was
a palace where he remained for his own
safety the creature's continued good
behavior and everyone else's safety
relied on visitors keeping up that line
Maxwell had never worked in this area of
the facility so a lot of the standard
procedures were new to him still his
Superior had given him a clear directive
talk to the monster communicate with him
be cordial and friendly see if you can
find out more about his mysterious past
and most importantly if you want to
survive don't annoy him the down on this
luck scientist gulped inside trying to
steady his nerves in this oversized fake
french Palace
he just kept thinking surely he can't be
that big he almost talked himself into
believing that the accounts of the
creature were just that tall tales until
a huge figure began lumbering into the
main chamber it was him
scp-082 also known as Fernand the
cannibal
scp-082 was an eight foot tall hulking
monster built sturdier than the castles
it likes to imagine are its true home
swollen bloated and grossly out of
proportion the creature clocks in at
over 700 pounds
most of which is pure muscle that's
almost impossible to pierce with
conventional Weaponry
scp-082 stopped just feet away and
stared at Dr Maxwell with its Beady
sunken in eyes like a hungry rat
just the sight of it struck Terror into
Dr Maxwell's heart but he didn't dare
show his fear instead he remembered his
brief training bowing politely and
forcing a smile referring to the
creature as your highness and profusely
thanking it for granting him an audience
the monster continued staring without
saying anything and then gave a wide
lockjawed grin showing off its huge
teeth it did everything through gritted
teeth except eat and sing Dr Maxwell
hoped he wouldn't be a part of either
activity
Fernand gave a low booming chuckle he
thanked Dr Maxwell for coming to give
him some company and invited him to come
further inside and take a seat adding
with a slight Wing that he won't bite
the monster complained that he so rarely
gets visitors to the Palace these days
but he omitted the fact that the main
reason for this was his tendency to
devour them Maxwell nodded and followed
the giant deeper into its oversized
above he couldn't help but notice that
the monster's arms looked like huge
fleshy punching bags he knew that if
Ferdinand wanted to he could easily
crush him flat just like he'd done to so
many unfortunate guards during
containment breaches
Fernand told Dr Maxwell that he was
thinking of having some decorating work
done the walls of his Palace were
starting to look awfully draft and he
gestured to one covered with a rusty red
streak Maxwell remembered that d-class
cleaners were sent into the containment
cell twice a month to tidy any of
ferdinand's messes but they often ended
up becoming one of the messes themselves
the creature encouraged Maxwell to take
a seat at his oversized dining table
while he tended to a pot of what he said
was full of delicious onion soup Maxwell
obliged his host's request and took a
seat at a huge chair that made him look
like a six-year-old sitting at the
grown-ups table meanwhile Fernand was
using a huge machete-like knife to
cleave onions in half for his bubbling
pot of stew even though Ferdinand had
shown no signs of outward aggression as
he watched the cannibal hack away at
onions with his enormous knife Maxwell
could feel himself beginning to sweat
after all they didn't call this creature
the cannibal for nothing this was a
monster with a truly horrifying body
count during previous containment
breaches it had taken enough
tranquilizer to put down two elephants
to subdue the creature but not before
multiple agents quite literally lost
their heads in the process Fernand was
able to bite them off with one huge
Chomp like he was eating a drumstick
snapping right through the bone with his
incredible tooth and jaw strength
surprisingly when he wasn't on a violent
Rampage Foundation researchers had found
scp-082 to be unusually polite and
forthcoming offering the researchers
plenty of information about himself and
his past
the only problem was that almost
everything the creature said was a
complete lie from his time as a
researcher Maxwell knew that there were
only a few details about the creature
that could be ascertained for certain
scp-082 would reliably answer to the
name Fernand and genetically Ferdinand
was technically human the means by which
Ferdinand became so grotesquely huge
strong and cannibalistic are still
unknown Foundation Personnel are still
looking into whether it's due to some
kind of anomalous genetic mutation or by
more Supernatural means all we know is
that he's big unpredictable and
extremely dangerous Dr Robert Maxwell
sat terrified at the dining table of
scp-082 listening to fernand's slightly
dull blade chopped through the final
onion which he then tossed into the
boiling soup
fernan had switched the topic of
conversation to one of his favorite
fictional characters Hannibal Lecter of
course Hannibal the cannibal isn't quite
so fictional to fernan while he's been
shown to be extremely intelligent in
terms of puzzle solving and memory he
seems to have no understanding of the
distinctions between fiction and reality
he assumes all movies and TV shows are a
form of documentary or reality
television and ever since seeing the
Silence of the Lambs Ferdinand has been
eager to meet with Dr Lecter which he
emphasized to Maxwell over and over
since trying to explain the concept of
fiction to Ferdinand had never
previously worked Maxwell simply told
him that Dr Lecter is extremely busy at
the moment but will visit whenever he
gets a chance this seemed to satisfy
Ferdinand who placed two large bowls of
steaming soup on the table before
sitting down a little too close to
Maxwell he couldn't help but notice that
the giant cannibal was now sitting with
inviting distance and as a lowly d-class
nobody would be rushing in to save him
if things went South Fernand began
ranting through his clenched teeth once
more occasionally stopping to consume a
hefty spoonful of onion soup Maxwell was
sure to do the same not wanting to seem
anything less than polite but soon the
tenor of ferdinand's rant began to shift
typically the monster spoke French or
heavily accented English
now he was affecting the accent of a
Victorian gentleman peppering a speech
with Tally Ho and the game is afoot
Maxwell was confused at first but
quickly realized the game Ferdinand was
playing it's well known that Ferdinand
is a pathological liar who likes to play
numerous characters changing his
mannerisms and clothes accordingly these
personas have included a vampire Big
Bird Andre the Giant Foundation
researcher Dr bright The Incredible Hulk
Alexander the Great Captain Hook Dr
Frankenstein and Frankenstein's monster
and of course in this case
the iconic fictional detective Sherlock
Holmes fearing for his life in this
strange situation Dr Maxwell did the
only thing he could play along as fernan
reeled off his homsy and delusions
Maxwell began to play the role of Dr
John Watson asking follow-up questions
and complimenting ferdinand's impeccable
deductive reasoning and it seemed to be
working Ferdinand played along too
acting as though the two of them really
were Arthur Conan Doyle's crime fighting
Duo towards the end of their game Dr
Maxwell was even starting to enjoy it
amazed that his quick thinking was
actually keeping him safe but just then
the cannibal froze as if in a trance he
locked eyes with Dr Maxwell like a mad
dog that you can't tell if it's going to
bite you or not he saw the creatures
gargantuan teeth separating its huge
Jaws stretching open this could surely
only mean one thing Dr Maxwell Winston
prepared for death cursing that all of
his quick thinking had amounted to to
nothing
Fernand leaned towards him his gaping
maw with its hot onion scented breath
just inches away from Maxwell and then
he began to sing the cannibal broke into
a raucous Victorian Pub song happy and
jovial in his moment of Terror Dr
Maxwell had forgotten that this was the
other reason scp-082 opens his
nightmarish Jaws relief washed over him
as he knew he was safe at least for the
moment
not long after Foundation guards arrived
and escorted him from the cell leaving
the delusional giant to his own devices
back in the so-called Palace
the former researcher had done it he had
vested Ferdinand the cannibal and
hopefully it would be the last time he'd
ever be face to face with that deranged
Giant unfortunately for Dr Robert
Maxwell in a performance review later
that week one of his superiors remarked
that Ferdinand enjoyed his company and
he had done a great job such a good job
in fact that Ferdinand insisted he had
Dr Maxwell for dinner or any other meal
for that matter
sometime very soon a veteran worker of
the SCP Foundation sits at his terminal
performing one of the most critical
tasks in the entire organization
creating a file for an as yet
undescribed SCP but there's something
terribly wrong his eyes are glazed over
his mouth hangs open is this a zombie or
a trained Foundation researcher
what is going on like any large
International Organization it takes more
than just the exciting action-filled
jobs to keep the wheels turning at the
SCP Foundation sure the head researchers
guards mobile task force soldiers and
members of the o5 command get all the
praise but a legion of number crunchers
cleaners and paper pushers are equally
important one such person was archivist
Walter Bainbridge who had been tasked
with digitizing some of the older
records that the foundation had on file
it was when he was innocently recording
the details on
scp-050-3060 that he first came under
the strange and startling effects of
scp-055 but the most peculiar part as
with all incidents of
scp-055's anomalous effects taking hold
is that Walter had no idea any of it was
happening in this new digitized filing
system he first took note of scp-053
Euclid class also known as the young
girl this anomaly was a seemingly normal
human female child who provoked
homicidal Insanity in those directly
exposed to her then scp-054 safe class
a non-aggressive humanoid female made
entirely of as well as biologically and
chemically identical to regular Spring
Water next
scp-056 Euclid Class A being that
changes form to suit its environment but
only when all observers lose focus of it
and then
scp-057 safe class an underground
chamber that crushes the humans who walk
Within it was at this point that Walter
received a concerned message from one of
his superiors at site 19 Mr Kovach the
message praised the thorough
digitization of the other anomaly's
records but was confused about why
Walter had left out any mention of
scp-055 immediately Walter was
embarrassed how could he have forgotten
scp-055 that iconic anomaly known for
well he couldn't quite say off the top
of his head but he'd be sure to look
into it a quick trip to the site-19
archive showed him that there was
actually quite a hefty file on the
nature of
scp-055 which must have been the result
of a huge number of studies what struck
him as strange was that all the files
were filled out in pen rather than being
typed up like a traditional file the
majority of these notes were written in
shorthand too as though they were
frantically taken during the tests
themselves on extremely short notice
there weren't even any redactions Walter
made a mental note of what he had seen
put the file back in its proper place
and headed back to his computer terminal
however after riding in an almost
trance-like stay he looked back on his
work to see that he had written an entry
on
scp-058 a giant evil bovine heart with
insect legs and a scorpion Stinger
strange he thought that's when Walter
got a call from Mr Kovach on his
foundation issue phone and he didn't
sound happy he'd given Walter direct
instructions to go back and digitize the
files on zero five five and instead he'd
been working on zero five a what was the
meaning of This Walter was typically an
extremely loyal and diligent employee
but the verbal barrage from his
supervisor had him considering talking
back just this once and hoping it didn't
get him demoted to d-class and thrown
into 682's Acid Bath for playtime Walter
Galt picked up some courage and
interrupted Mr kovach's rant to ask if
he had any idea what scp-055 actually
was the line went silent for a moment
then his supervisor spoke again this
time with less confidence of course I
can tell you about
scp-055 it's a classic one of the first
hundred how could you forget it's uh uh
or yeah you know it's I think it's the
one with um
another long pause as Mr Kovach seemed
to search for the words but instead just
trailed off into silence knowing that
some of the anomalies on file were
dangerous mimetic hazards Walter was
worried for a moment that he may have
accidentally killed his boss by getting
him to think too hard about
scp-055 he asked if Mr Kovach was okay
and finally got a reply
I'm sorry I seem to have zoned out for a
second there what were we talking about
again
but this time it was Walter who couldn't
answer he had no idea at all what the
two of them were discussing just moments
ago he felt disoriented and kind of sick
like they'd taken some low level
amnesics Mr Kovach told Walter to get
back to his filing duties and they'd
speak later Walter then checked the
messages he'd received from Mr Kovach
earlier and there it was plain as day
you missed zero five five go back and
digitize that before proceeding Mr K but
Walter had never even heard of an
scp-055 if such an anomaly even existed
what was going on here in that moment
Walter realized he was dealing with
something much Stranger Than Just a
standard digitization job after all how
could he properly complete his duties of
scp-055 seemed to be impossible to speak
right or even think about unless you
were directly observing it at that
moment Walter had to know and ask around
the entirety of site 19 to find the
answers if he had to
sadly for Walter he was about to embark
on a much more challenging task than he
could have ever imagined to paraphrase a
supposed quote from Socrates all I know
is that I know nothing and that's also
about the extent of the knowledge we
have on
scp-055 also known as the anti-mean and
the self-keeping secret what does it
look like when and how was it obtained
by the foundation what are its anomalous
abilities the this thing dangerous we
may never know because the only
anomalous ability of scp-055 that we're
aware of is the fact that nobody is
capable of retaining any information
about it it's crucial to note that
whatever 055 is it isn't invisible or
Indescribable Foundation Personnel are
perfectly capable of entering its
containment chamber and observing it
without incident but mere minutes after
leaving the chamber any memories of the
particulars of 055 seem to spontaneously
erase themselves
hence the self-keeping secret but this
didn't deter Walter perhaps his greatest
Advantage was that he didn't know enough
about the thing he was investigating to
know how futile his mission was he
wanted to know the unknowable and a
pesky issue like impossibility wouldn't
stop him he'd get to whoever he needed
to at site 19 to get the answers he
needed of course most people had no
knowledge of the mysterious anomaly the
common response he got back from his
colleagues was zero five five do we even
have a zero five five well the
realization of sudden memory loss or the
realization of 055's existence has been
known to cause momentary stress there
are no known long-term physical or
mental effects from zero five five's
anomalous abilities it's a fleeting idea
in its purest form like forgetting why
you walked into a room zero five five
could be the most harmless object on the
foundation's roster or the most deadly
either way we just don't know at times
Walter worried he was going insane zero
five five and everything related to it
was gaslighting him with zero five five
even real the one thing that proved to
him that zero five five must have
existed is that its containment chamber
existed
according to the official records kept
by the foundation on the site-19
containment facilities
zero five five is kept in a five by five
by 2.5 meter Square Room constructed of
50-foot thick cement with a faraday cage
surrounding the cement walls the report
continues that access is via a heavy
containment door measuring 2 by 2.5
meters constructed on bearings to ensure
door closes and locks automatically
unless held open deliberately
zero five five cell is one of the few to
have no posted security guards and any
Personnel working on other scps in the
area are ordered to remain at least 50
feet from the geometric Center of zero
five five cell
where the anomaly itself is capped when
he tried to explore further why the cell
was constructed in this manner he found
that surprise surprise nobody knew
055 was an anomaly whose containment
requirements were so mysterious that it
automatically netted itself a ketter
class designation after all how can you
properly contain something you can't
even hope to comprehend there were
plenty of rumors about the true nature
of 055
some of the more conspiratorial Minds at
site 19 theorized that 055 was actually
an autonomous or remotely controlled spy
inserted into the site to observe
Foundation operations or even Humanity
as a whole if you're on the more
paranoid end of the psychological
Spectrum this Theory makes total sense
an anomaly that's physically impossible
to remember even when writings and
pictures on the subject exist would be a
perfect spy however this was all
ultimately little more than speculation
Walter was barely any further along than
when he started there were multiple
points in his investigations where
Walter seriously considered giving up
until finally he had a major
breakthrough Dr Bartholomew Hughes and
Dr John marichek were two scientists
that had performed extensive research
into zero five five and who Walter hoped
might have the answers he sought about
the self-keeping secret these scientists
were the first to discover the
anti-memetic nature of 055 performing
numerous tests on d-class Personnel to
see if it was possible to create
feasible written records sketches or any
other records or Impressions that could
bypass its anomalous effects the
disorienting memory ruining effects of
055 also extend to any materials
concerning 055 it seems to be a truly
uncrackable code but Dr Hughes may have
finally found some cracks in the armor
for starters the fact that we're able to
remember that zero five five is an
anti-memetic is an ironic exception to
its anti-memetic qualities this
Revelation also inspired another
realization from Dr Hughes
would it be possible to discover more
about zero five five from the process of
deduction rather than the typical
induction in other words could they
possibly learn about zero five five by
figuring out all the things it isn't
rather than what it is Dr marichek
designed an experiment with Dr Hughes to
explore this Theory they designed the
experiment around a simple question is
055 not spherical in designing the
question to specifically find out what
055 isn't they hope to subvert the
anomaly's anti-memetic powers Walter was
fascinated by this potential method of
getting answers marichek and Hughes
found that while the questioning process
for those exposed was often arduous and
frustrating they could now definitely
say that 055 is not a sphere it is
theoretically possible to discover the
true nature of 055 by an almost endless
barrage of deductive questions though
whether command would authorize the
resource sources for such extensive
testing is still an open question Walter
and his desperation begged marichek and
Hughes for clearance to view zero five
five himself the Curiosity had become
too great during a search to just walk
away with the single fact that zero five
five wasn't spherical he needed to see
this thing and after several weeks of
filling out forms and cutting red tape
his wish was finally granted Walter
Bainbridge was allowed a private
audience with
scp-055 the subject of his months-long
obsession Outsiders observe that Walter
spent just over an hour in the
containment chamber taking photos
drawing sketches writing down notes
recording audio logs and reciting memory
mnemonics he was pulling out every stop
to counteract the anti-memetic effects
of the self-keeping secret he was
adamant that he would not be defeated by
his non-spherical Nemesis not after all
this time and effort once his time in
the 055 containment chamber was over he
retired back to his office to finally
digitize his exhaustive findings so that
his supervisor Mr Kovach would finally
get off his back Walter smiled took a
deep breath and began to type
scp-059 ketter class this anomaly is a
radioactive mineral that emits a unique
radiation known as Delta radiation
exposure to this radiation has caused
strange fungal growth on the infected
wait what was this supposed to be about
again oh well it couldn't have been that
important the fabric of our world is
littered with strange doorways if you
know where to look for them Terrors
portals anomalies all leading to places
and planes Beyond human imagining and
understanding an
scp-2317 otherwise known as a door to
another world certainly fits that
description
contained and kept at all times under
the watch of armed guards
scp-2317 appears to be a simple and
unsuspecting wooden door in its frame
it hardly looks like it requires such
extreme round-the-clock security or
needs a strange secretive ritual that
the foundation performs presumably to
keep the door closed
but of course sometimes the most
interesting thing about a closed doorway
isn't where it leads it's what it keeps
out
even by the foundation's already high
standards the requirements and
regulations for personnel who are
assigned to scp-2317 seem oddly specific
psychological testing is standard
practice to work for the foundation but
an additional hurdle that anyone has to
clear before even getting to Glimpse at
this unassuming wooden door is having a
score of at least 72 on the Milgram
obedience examination
it is also mandatory that Personnel
assigned to maintaining it are both
unmarried with no children or next of
kin as well as an unwavering
unquestioning loyalty to the foundation
pure devotion to its code and objectives
these may seem like strange requirements
after all
scp-2317 is just a door isn't it
perhaps there's a reason that the
foundation keeps so much of the
information about
scp-2317 buried deep under layers upon
layers of security with only the
overseer Council privy to the full
details of its strange nature
knowledge as they say is power but maybe
knowing too much about whatever is
behind that door can prove deadly
still if scp-2317 is a door to another
world an alternate Dimension or parallel
reality it must be safe enough to visit
after all the foundation has been
sending Personnel in there on a regular
basis daily in fact
according to the o5 council this is done
as part of a procedure to maintain
active containment of something lurking
beyond that old wooden door frame
but what could possibly warrant such
constant maintenance and surveillance
in accordance with the foundation's
guidelines all staff are required to
rotate out of observing scp-2317 after
every two months and spend the following
third month in full psychological
counseling before they are permitted to
return to the containment unit housing
the door to another world
it was after one of these month-long
periods of evaluation that a foundation
guard was informed that his security
clearance has been raised to level three
and that he'd been selected for the duty
of carrying out 220 Calabasas he knew
the name instantly
this was the title given to the Daily
containment procedure that absolutely
had to be carried out
the guard didn't question these orders
after all he'd been selected precisely
because of his loyalty to the foundation
he did make one request to his
commanding officer however
he wanted to know what had happened to
the last guard that had performed the
procedure
didn't make it out of psychological
evaluation
the officer replied
not letting this affect his dedication
the guard was told to prepare for
procedure 220 Calabasas
along with a fellow member of foundation
security personnel the guard was
instructed to gather everything on a
strange list
the first was a pre-selected member of
Class D personnel
specifically a convicted murderer class
D refers to disposable class Personnel
Expendable individuals recruited by the
foundation for the sole purpose of
testing scps
class D's were usually prison inmates
repurposed for SCP testing and the one
chosen for 220 Calabasas was no
exception serving multiple life
sentences for murders or at least that's
what the guard had been told
a foundation Personnel member instructed
him to refer to the class D's solely as
the assistant from that point on
next the guard collected a live chicken
an obsidian edged knife a silver
aspergalum and aspersorium to be filled
with 500 cc's of holy water that have
been blessed by a priest of the
abrahamic faith and finally a one
kiloton nuclear device which according
to instructions was only to be detonated
in the unlikely event of a catastrophic
containment failure in other words The
Last Resort
after following his instructions to the
letter and without question the guard
and his colleague were briefed the
foundation Personnel member informed
them that he'd be joining and leading
them in the procedure the staff member
also specified that henceforth he'd be
referred to as the celebrant until the
completion of 220 Calabasas the guard
was acutely aware of how specific these
instructions were but trusted in the
foundation knowing that if they wanted
this procedure performed a certain way
then it was in everyone's best interest
to carry out the orders to the letter
but what the celebrant then went on to
explain raised far more questions about
scp-2317s and the nature of procedure
220 Calabasas
the class D joining them wasn't actually
a Class D
the assistant as they were now referred
to was in reality another Foundation
staff member with a level 4 security
clearance specifically tailored to
scp-2317
every member of Staff entering through
scp-2317 and taking an active role in 22
Calabasas needed to be informed that
this assistant was not to be harmed or
treated as a member of disposable class
fighting back the nagging question of
why the foundation would employ this
subterfuge the guard along with his
fellow security officer the celebrant
and assistant prepared for their
departure through the door to another
world at solar noon when the sun was
highest over scp-2317
solar noon chickens and holy water
this all seemed like an oddly occult
combination for the foundation
as they entered the old wooden door
Beyond lay a Barren salt plain
stretching out for kilometers in every
direction
this alternate Dimension according to
the briefing was designated
scp-2317 Prime the guard immediately
noticed a ring of Seven Pillars directly
ahead of the group as they entered
each of them bearing intricately
detailed Engravings unlike anything from
any era of ancient history
procedure 220 Calabasas was carried out
quickly but carefully the guard watching
as the celebrant and assistant were
careful not to miss a step
first the celebrant scattered holy water
into the center of the pillars with the
aspergelum and aspersorium looking down
at his feet and keeping a steady Pace as
he stepped counterclockwise around them
the guard watched intently as the
celebrant completed his circuit around
the pillars and turned to the assistant
anointing his head with holy water
Seven Seals seven rings
seven Thrones for the Scarlet King he
said aloud
the assistant with the obsidian blade in
his hand took the chicken and dispatched
it in sacrifice
letting its blood mix with the holy
water
he then repeated the celebrant circuit
in the opposite direction before
stepping into the center of the stone
pillars
blood for the old gods water for the new
king the assistant recited pouring the
remaining mix of blood and holy water
over a patch of salt in the middle of
the Seven Pillars
even though he knew it wasn't his place
to question the foundation as the 220
Calabasas procedure took place the guard
couldn't help but wonder what all this
was for
it seems so ritualistic like something
deeply religious or even magical he
never bought into all that occult mumbo
jumbo even while working for the
foundation but he had learned not to
question anything even the strangest and
most inexplicable of science
little did he know that beneath his feet
was an ancient and unknowable horror a
beast Chained and lying in weight
contained in a chamber directly
underneath the pillars sat an impossibly
large creature
humanoid and obese its body covered
entirely in Scales thicker than armor
plating
branch-like horns protruded from its
jawless head pointing up to chains that
hung from the Seven Pillars above
each one hooked into the entity's back
all but one of the chains was broken a
final withering shackle keeping the
Devourer of Worlds and its underground
prison
ever since 1894 BCE when origin Mystics
imprisoned it the Devourer has been
waiting patiently for its inevitable
freedom
it knows as well as the foundation that
nothing can be done to prevent the final
chain from one day breaking even
procedure 220 Calabasas won't keep the
creature contained
it's nothing more than a smoke screen an
act designed to create an illusion of
active containment and maintain
Foundation morale until a permanent
solution can be devised to keep
scp-2317 imprisoned of course if the
guard had known this it would have also
explained the need for a one kiloton
nuclear device as part of this stage
ritual
procedure 220 Calabasas had all the
components to trick everyone below the
o5 council emulating religious and
occult rituals The increased level of
security surrounding the procedure and
its purpose
and telling staff that any failure to
correctly and completely perform the 220
Calabasas procedure will result in an XK
Class end of the world scenario
all these elements work together to
conceal the truth that one day the
Devourer will escape and lay waste to
our dimension
knowledge is power and maybe knowing too
much truly is deadly perhaps if the
guard had learned any of this he'd have
understood why his predecessor never
made it out of psychological evaluation
maybe if he had questioned the purpose
of procedure 220 Calabasas he'd have
learned the true nature of scp-2317
and what that doorway kept out
but he was loyal to the foundation
through and through
as the team finished performing 220
Calabasas and returned through the
wooden door the guard took one last
glance over his shoulder at the vast
salt plane
the entire Dimension was calm silent
but not peaceful it was patient The
Entity had waited centuries for its time
and now all it would take was the
breaking of the seventh and final chain
one day the door was closed behind the
guard as he the celebrant the assistant
and his fellow security officers stepped
back through
their work done and as far as they knew
preventing catastrophe for another day
only the foundation higher-ups the
overseer Council are aware of the true
danger posed by
scp-2317 and its sole inhabitant
current predictions are that at some
point within the next 30 Years the
Devourer of Worlds will be freed
any and all attempts to repair or
recreate the chains holding it in place
have so far failed as such the o5
council has elected to continue
providing Foundation personnel with the
ignorant hope that procedure 220
Calabasas is an effective strategy for
containment as we've said
sometimes the most interesting thing
about a closed door isn't where it leads
it's what it keeps out
in the case of
scp-2317 the unassuming wooden door
holds at Bay an ancient creature of
Untold power
that will one day break free and wreak
havoc in our dimension
nothing the foundation does can prevent
it or keep it contained behind the door
to another world
and only the overseer Council knows that
any and all efforts to do so are futile
with all that in mind we can only hope
that the doorway of
scp-2317 stays closed
at least for a little while longer
it was November 3rd 1991 and Blake
Newsome loved his job he had a passion
for organization an Undying Love of
American political history and was a
lifelong member of the Republican party
that's why he took great pride in his
position as a filing clerk at the Ronald
Reagan Presidential Library or at least
he did until his horrifying encounter
with
scp-1981 the worst day of Blake's life
began like any other he was taking
inventory of the archive's wide array of
betamax tapes and making sure that they
were all arranged carefully and
conformed with the filing system one by
one he checked footage of speeches and
addresses off of his list until he came
upon a strange tape that had no business
being there the tape looked to be
completely normal but it hadn't been
recorded on the archive inventory and
there was something else off about it a
single white sticker was on the front of
the tape with Ronald Reagan cut up while
talking squalled hastily with what was
probably a felt tip marker
Blake was shocked in a palm they hadn't
even spelled the president's name
correctly
what poor Mr Newsome didn't know was
that he was about to see something so
disturbing that he'd look back on that
misspelling like it was a treasured
childhood memory
standard policy for tapes like this
would be to review and catalog or even
throw it out if necessary typically a
lowly filing clerk like Blake would need
to seek approval from his superiors but
curiosity got the better of him he
commandeered one of the library's
televisions and betamax cassette players
and started watching the footage for the
first minute or so nothing seemed out of
the ordinary
just the president standing at the
podium giving his iconic evil empire
speech to the National Association of
evangelicals at Sheraton Twin Towers
Hotel Orlando Florida on March 8 1983.
however the second the tape hit the one
minute and 10 seconds Mark something
unnatural began to occur President
Reagan's speech began to Veer off as the
topic of conversation shifted from the
importance of family values to the
Exquisite Taste of human flesh Blake was
taken aback but surely he was hearing
things but the tape only got worse
President Reagan began to divulge the
fact that he enjoyed the taste of young
flesh the best particularly that of
infants as Reagan began to go into
detail about how exactly one should best
cook an infant if you want to seal in
the flavor the crowd erupted into modest
Applause Blake started to feel sick he'd
remembered watching this speech and
President Reagan had said nothing of the
sore
things only got weirder as the
president's cheek suddenly opened up
into a long bleeding gash as though
someone had cut into his face with an
invisible knife has the speech continued
and Reagan's words became more
nonsensical and incoherent the injuries
got worse too his face developed
puncture wounds like he was being
stabbed skin in some areas rotted and
peeled off Reagan showed no awareness of
the horrifying injuries that seemed to
be occurring spontaneously on his body
this was a living nightmare the tape
came to a merciful end 22 minutes in
after President Reagan's throat appeared
to be slashed open and his insane speech
was reduced to quiet gurgles
it fizzled out into static shortly after
and Blake politely retired to the
bathroom to throw up
was this some sick prank or tampering or
camera trickery perhaps he didn't know
but the tape was disgusting and whoever
was responsible had to be punished
Newsome contacted the police hoping
obscenity charges could be pressed
against the creator of the tape once
they were found the tape was taken into
evidence and a low-level police
investigation into the possible culprits
began while the police officers who
viewed the tape reported nightmares in
the weeks following the creator of the
tape was never found the investigation
truly came to an end when a superior
closed the case and the tape disappeared
from the evidence Locker this as you
probably could have guessed was the work
of a field agent from the SCP Foundation
anistics were then used to erase the
memories of everyone unlucky enough to
witness the tape including Blake Newsome
who could finally rest easy and return
to his filing work
the anomalous tape was now in
responsible hands it was given the
designation
scp-1981 and given the object class safe
due to its easily controlled and
self-contained nature proper research
and testing was now able to begin and
while nothing about the construction of
the tape suggested anything inherently
anomalous repeat viewings of the video
made it clear that this went far beyond
mere doctored footage of a presidential
speech every single time the tape is
played both the speech made and the
injuries received by President Reagan
change the few rules the tape seem to
always follow are that Reagan never
reacts to the injuries he's receiving it
always has the same beginning and total
run time and the speech is always
corrupted the speeches have been
described as mostly incoherent lacking
any sort of underlying thematic
structure and largely being composed of
nonsensical anecdotes and parables so
not that dissimilar from a regular
Reagan speech but the topics always turn
incredibly dark and have included
torture mutilation death cannibalism
ritual sacrifice genocide and more
the range of injuries shown on President
Reagan in the videos have included but
are by no means limited to impalement
mutilation and some tortures so gruesome
that the details have been redacted from
official files on several occasions the
details of President Reagan's speech
have also eerily predicted the Future
these include successfully predicting
the September 11th attacks in 2001 and
the outcome of the 2008 Russian
presidential election incidentally this
isn't even the only reagan-related SCP
to predict the future
no there's another entity in this
incredibly specific Niche
scp-095 a highly degraded copy of a
comic known as the atomic Adventures of
Ronnie raygun
the Title Character Bears a striking
resemblance to President Reagan despite
the fact that the comment is confirmed
by Foundation tests to have been written
in the early 1930s
the comic is set in the far-off future
world of the 1980s and follows a number
of Ronnie's exploits in three stories
the first titled Ronnie vs Space Admiral
Carter seems to perfectly describe the
events of the 1980 presidential election
the second space assassin mirrors the
attempted assassination of President
Reagan by John Hinckley Jr and the third
titled jungle Planet retells the
Iran-Contra controversies of 1986.
these Comics were produced under the
mysterious and apparently non-existing
company future funnies the foundation
helps to track down the other comics
from this company whenever possible but
they've had no luck on that front for
now there's only
scp-095 during initial testing
Foundation staff watched the tape
frequently in case this strange
corrupted version of President Reagan
had any other valuable predictions for
the future
however during one of these screenings
one of the d-class observation Personnel
pointed and yelled at the screen in
horror upon further examination of
recorded footage researchers could see
exactly what had concerned The d-class
Observer so much
while in other viewings of the tape
President Reagan's press detail had
appeared totally normal and this one
something was clearly amiss standing
among the other dull suit-wearing
political AIDS was a tall figure dressed
in a midnight black cloak with a large
conical Hood obscuring his face the
figure didn't appear to move in the
footage it just stood there menacingly a
later survey indicated that this figure
would appear in roughly one in seven
viewings of the tape
this cloaked figure was designated
scp-1981-1 and he became part of the
reoccurring imagery in the nightmares
that often followed a viewing of
scp-1981.
naturally despite containment and
preservation attempts the foundation was
aware that just like any normal tape
natural magnetic interference would
eventually degrade it Beyond use
attempts to copy the footage onto
another betamax tape failed to reproduce
the anomalous effects that's why the
foundation has painstakingly recorded
any video and audio they could via
standard commercial camcorder in one
particularly terrifying playback
scp-1981-1 took the president's place at
the podium staring directly into the
camera the words I see you appeared over
a black screen shortly after staff
members were ordered never to make an
attempt at communicating with the figure
and instead contact a level 4 Superior
if such an event occurs during a
playback again
the frightening and unfortunate effects
of scp-1981 would come to their logical
conclusion under the watchful eye of Dr
James Kyle Robinson managing archivist
of inert safe class objects and
anomalous items at site 73. he was
contacted by special agent Arnold
Rodriguez and special agent Ethan Tate
members of the Secret Service with a
duty to protect President Reagan word
had gotten to Reagan that there was an
anomalous artifact in the possession of
the foundation that directly pertained
to him and he wanted to see it
Dr Robinson obtained files and
transcripts pertaining to scp-1981 and
handed them over to the agents but
refused to allow President Reagan to see
the tape directly without approval from
o5 command but Reagan and the Agents
were persistent eventually o5 command
ordered a private screening of the tape
for President Reagan at the Sanford
chemical processing plan a front
business owned and operated by the
foundation for amnesic production Dr
Robinson offered President Reagan the
use of amnestics after the session
completed but Reagan declined the
screening took place in conference room
B and the tape was replayed three times
it was on the third playback that things
took an interesting turn as the
mutilated Reagan on the screen began to
rant about drinking the blood of a child
from the skull of Vladimir Putin Reagan
began to silently mouth along the words
as though he remembered them he spoke
about beings known as the Destroyers and
potential apocalyptic events to come
after the screening Reagan once again
refused the offer of amnestics and
departed
it seemed as though all was well until a
violent break-in at the Sanford chemical
processing plant that left a night guard
dead
a large number of amnestics had been
stolen during the break-in and security
footage showed that agent Tate and
Rodriguez had been responsible the two
agents were tracked down and traced to
the residents of Ronald Reagan where the
foundation Came Upon a disturbing site
the agents had pillaged large quantities
of Class A and B and mistakes and
supplied them to President Reagan who at
some point after observing scp-1981 had
been driven into a dangerous Madness the
two agents wanted to cure him before he
caused harm to himself or others but
their bungling had come with severe
consequences misapplying such a high
quantity of amnestics had essentially
destroyed Reagan's mind while the
foundation was able to stabilize his
condition his impaired memory and
cognitive function would leave him
unable to care for himself independently
in order to cover up for this Grievous
mistake a cover story was concocted
about Reagan falling victim to
Alzheimer's and facing severe cognitive
decline as a result
both agents tayden Rodriguez were fired
for their actions had their memories
wiped by the foundation and were
assigned new identities Dr Robinson for
his part in the disaster had to face a
foundation Ethics Committee disciplinary
hearing
while scp-1981 continues to be
classified as safe due to its
unlikeliness to ever breach containment
when you consider the havoc and Rod on
the mind of its singular Target safe is
hardly the word that comes to mind it's
enough to make you wonder what other
tapes are lurking out there just waiting
to be found the young girl stood
silently in a room full of corpses
staring off into the distance
she was in a trance seemingly unaware of
the Carnage that had just unfolded
around her some of the men were shot or
stabbed or beaten others had no apparent
cause of death whatsoever but the young
girl was unscathed she was wearing a
yellow summer dress and looked like she
couldn't have been more than three years
old she awoke from her trance still
paying no heed to the violence in the
room and left this is the story of
scp-053 the young girl her strange and
terrifying life before containment her
thrilling capture
and the parts she played in one of the
most dangerous SCP Foundation cross
tests of all time she had no name the
young girl could never spend enough time
around someone to be given one it was
her terrible courage that she could
never stay in one place for too long or
something truly awful would happen to
everyone around her she'd been drifting
for years but never grew to look older
than a child her memories were long but
formless divided mostly into 10-minute
increments the young girl kept on moving
it was all she could do in 1993 when the
young girl had already been alive for a
very long time she found herself in
Illinois after days of trekking on the
roadside she would scavenge what little
food she needed from the trash and drink
from lakes rivers or even puddles when
she needed to deep down the young girl
knew that if she ever grew hungry or
thirsty
she would not die in her travels the
young girl had managed to scrounge
together a few dollars and though she
knew her contact with people had to be
limited
there was one thing she wanted that felt
worth the risk a candy bar had been a
long time since she tasted chocolate and
she found the idea of tasting it again
too enticing to resist when she reached
Chicago she entered a small corner store
with her handful of dollars selected the
candy bar from the rack and approached
the counter for reasons even she didn't
fully understand she kept her eyes down
as she placed the money on the counter
see scp-053 was always a special child
as we briefly mentioned earlier you
might even say she was cursed whenever
she was around other people for too long
Terrible Things tended to happen
unspeakable things and as a component of
this strange unexplainable curse or
perhaps as a means of keeping her safe
from it the young girl was doomed to
never understand the nature of her
predicament it was like there was a
mental wall between her and the horrors
her presence could cause
all she knew was that it was best to
avoid eye contact
stay away from large groups of people at
all costs and never spend any longer
than 10 minutes around anyone
ever that's why as she waited for her
chocolate bar the cash register she kept
her head down and waited to go the
cashier looked Upon This Strange girl
with apparent concern it been a slow day
all in all a few listless patrons milled
around the store window shopping his
brain was practically on autopilot until
he saw this child she looked filthy in a
disheveled dress and was totally alone
what on Earth had happened to this child
the more he looked at her the more he
sensed a creepy Vibe exuding from her
something about this girl was wrong he
spoke softly to her introducing himself
as miles and asking her where her mommy
and daddy were
the young girl hesitated for just a few
seconds too long for his liking before
simply saying that they were at home any
parent who'd left their three-year-old
kid just wander around the south side of
Chicago alone was either crazy
neglectful or both
he asked her politely to remain in the
store while he gave the police a quick
call
he'd even let her have the candy bar for
free while she waited immediately the
little girl became uncomfortable she had
already been in here for a few minutes
now and while miles called the police he
expected her to wait around even longer
again she couldn't even tell you why she
knew waiting around like this would be
so dangerous but she had a nagging
instinctual awareness that she needed to
get out around the store the few patrons
still inside started to get a strange
feeling like someone was watching them
soon what seemed like mild paranoia was
quickly becoming white hot anger pure
rage they felt almost like they had to
kill someone but not just anyone
someone particular they had to kill the
little girl it wasn't long until the
police arrived two officers holiday and
DeWitt entered to collect the Apparently
neglected little girl
it was a story they'd sadly heard all
too often a tragically common occurrence
in the big city when the two of them
approached the young girl she was
looking down at the ground they tried to
speak to her but she was unresponsive
miles looked on concerned but deep down
he felt the same bizarre progression all
the other store-goers were feeling
Fusion irritability and finally violent
rage the corner store was a powder gig
all it needed now was a spark and that
spark came when officer holiday reached
down and took the young girl by the arm
his bare skin touched hers and it was
all over the cop twitched his mind
washed out in murderous Insanity as he
reached for his sidearm officer DeWitt
opened his mouth to protest but he
didn't manage to get a syllable out
before holiday turned and shot him in a
fraction of a second the quiet Corner
Store exploded into a violent bloodbath
as the patrons and cops slaughtered each
other all the while the young girl just
stood there in a trance everyone was
dead within minutes except miles and the
young girl he shakily rose to his feet
his mind carved out by Madness and
reached for officer holiday's discarded
pistol
outside of the store the young girl
appeared walking out as if nothing had
happened inside miles's body was
sprawled over the counter clutching his
chest as if his heart had just exploded
this was the true nature of the young
girl's curse anyone who meets her eye
touches her skin or spends over 10
minutes around her is destined to slip
into a state of murderous Insanity
they'll go into a kill crazy frenzy and
attack anyone around them until all that
is left is them and the young girl
at which point they'll try to kill her
too but the mere Act of attempting to
kill her is also fatal
killing its victims with a massive heart
attack or a seizure
the second part of the girl's curse is
that she herself can never die she keeps
coming back unknowingly causing more
misery and death along the way until of
course a certain secret organization
took notice that night the young girl
sat in the cavernous interior of a local
abandoned warehouse quietly eating her
hard-earned candy bar suddenly she heard
a quiet crack in the distance she tried
to move her left arm but found it was
numb she could barely move it the girl
turned her head and saw a tranquilizer
dart sticking out of her skin
instinctively she got up and began to
run limping as her left leg started to
lose all feeling too suddenly she was
surrounded by footsteps as masked men in
swat uniforms emerged out of the
darkness on all sides
the last thing she remembered before
slipping out of Consciousness was a
blindfold being pulled over her eyes and
Tiny metal handcuffs clasping over her
wrists when she woke up she was in the
nicest room she had slept in in years it
was 16 feet by 16 feet with toys books
and games
standing across the room from her was a
stranger in a full hazmat suit connected
to a long steel cable leading out of the
room he spoke calmly and politely a
timer on his wrist counted down from 10
minutes The Stranger explained to the
young girl that they would be taking
care of her now and would provide her
with all the toys and games and treats
she wanted provided she cooperated and
submitted willingly to some tests
compared to living out on the streets
with no food or Comfort this seemed like
an excellent compromise
she would live in what seemed like
luxury and every so often she'd be taken
to a testing room with a stranger and an
orange jumpsuit
after a few minutes of waiting The
Stranger would inevitably go feral and
attempt to kill her and then always die
in the process The Strangers in the
hazmat suits told her that all of these
tests were helping them learn extremely
valuable things about her and that soon
they'd have a very special job for her
it would be a wonderful surprise it was
the spring of 1994 that the young girl
now officially designated
scp-053 finally received her special
Mission several strangers in full hazmat
suits wielding rifles escorted her out
of her usual bedroom she asked where she
was being taken and was told she was
going to meet a new friend she was taken
to one of the recreational testing rooms
and pushed inside out in front of her
she saw something terrifying a giant
reptilian creature she retreated from an
instinctually hiding behind a chair in
the containment area the giant reptile
didn't move it just sat there eventually
she plucked up the courage to go and
touch the creature before retreating
again no reaction little by little the
young girl gained confidence and
continued to approach and Pat the
creature it exhaled through its huge
nostrils and the young girl literally
jumped for joy in her amusement
she began to play with the docile
monster hugging it even drawing on it
with a crayon The Observers were truly
baffled what the young girl didn't know
was that she was playing with
scp-682 one of the most hateful and
aggressive anomalies under the
foundation's watchful eye and yet in her
presence the creature was like an
overgrown puppy dog after the test phase
the young girl was removed from the hard
to kill reptile's presence immediately
causing the creature to become violent
and murderous once again
after being separated from her strange
new friend the young girl was seen
crying for several minutes
according to all accounts the young girl
is eager to see her friend again someday
though considering the reptile killed
several guards after their separation
the foundation isn't eager to Grant her
that wish
scp-053 was classified as Euclid and
continues to be held in containment with
her toys books and games rotated out on
a regular basis seeing as she shows no
sign of Aging this ongoing containment
is likely to be the sad strange fate of
the young girl an anomaly that never
wanted to hurt anyone but an important
and cruel reminder that what we want
doesn't always influence the world in
the way we want Joseph and Frank were
two lifelong squatchers no that isn't an
insult that's a self-given title for
bigfoot enthusiasts who are willing to
head out into the woods and search for
the legendary Sasquatch first hand while
most Watchers will go their whole lives
without ever encountering one Joseph and
Frank were about to get lucky they just
didn't know what kind of luck during a
journey through the forests of the
Pacific Northwest Frank spotted
something moving in the distance a huge
ape-like creature with grayish fur and
human-like movements Frank thought he
was finally laying eyes on the mighty
Bigfoot after Decades of searching what
he didn't know was that he just made a
deadly mistake he had looked directly at
scp-1000 and there would be terrible
consequences Frank was excited he just
achieved the life goal of any squatcher
he tapped Joseph on the shoulder and
directed him to look in the direction of
the creature Joseph followed Frank's
Direction and stared into the distance
when his eyes finally came into focus on
the ape-like Beast he froze his brain
just short-circuited one second he was
about to encounter the Holy Grail of his
Hobby and the next he was literally
brain dead Joseph collapsed in the
distance the ape-like creature
disappeared back into the woods not that
Frank even noticed he was too busy
trying to wake Joseph but it was no use
Jose Joseph was gone and Frank had no
idea why the headlines read Bigfoot
killed my friend most people either
ignored it or laughed it off just a
couple of cranks goofing off in a forest
and one of them had dropped dead who
cares well one organization cared the
SCP Foundation mobile task force Zeta
1000 the foundation's specialized
scp-1000 detail were alerted to the
reports they sprang into action tracking
down and detaining Frank for questioning
they process a million Looney Bigfoot
lovers every year and usually find
nothing but the death of Frank's friend
made it all too clear they hadn't
encountered a Bigfoot but a real genuine
example of scp-1000
scp-1000 rarely ranks among the scariest
or most dangerous scps but
underestimating the creature is a
terrible mistake because just looking at
it gives you a two percent chance of
dropping dead on the spot Frank despite
losing his friend was one of the lucky
ones the foundation debriefed him before
administering amnestics and making sure
that he'd never Venture back into those
mysterious forests in the Pacific
Northwest region director Jones the site
director charged with the management of
scp-1000 populations was given the
information on this latest case of an
scp-1000 related fatality it was a story
he heard many times before for director
Jones they all seem to bleed into one
another so what exactly is scp-1000 and
how did it leave poor Joseph dead in the
woods scp-1000 is a whole species of
large hominid ape-like creatures they're
largely nocturnal but sightings of the
creature during the day aren't unheard
of they're omnivorous mostly seeming to
consume plants and insects and their fur
is usually gray brown brown black red or
occasionally White
the creatures have large eyes capable of
impressive Vision nestled underneath a
pronounced neanderthal-like brow another
defining feature is the ridge of bone on
the forehead much like that of a gorilla
that is present in both sexes according
to Foundation studies the creatures
exhibit a level of Intelligence on par
with that of the common chimpanzee but
nowhere near that of us humans what they
lack in intelligence though they make up
for in size the adults can be as large
as 10 feet tall and weigh up to 600
pounds despite their great size and
impressive strength the creatures are
neither aggressive nor territorial in
fact they seem to instinctively avoid
humans mostly residing deep in the force
of the American Pacific Northwest and in
the Himalayan Alps there have been
sightings of scp-1000 on every continent
though the foundation has taken pains to
exterminate all scp-1000 populations
situated near human population centers
to prevent a potential disaster
considering the two percent chance of
instantaneous death upon visual contact
that brings us to to our second question
what is it that makes these seemingly
harmless creatures so dangerous sadly
for both these unfortunate creatures and
US humans the danger is beyond the
control of scp-1000
according to Foundation research
scp-1000 likely evolved alongside us
Homo sapiens until a tragedy occurred
between 10 and 15 000 years ago a
mysterious Extinction event eliminated
the vast majority of their species
leaving only one to five percent alive
in the aftermath what happened it's
believed that around this time scp-1000
contracted what the foundation refers to
as an anomalous pseudo-disease meet
scp-1000 F1 a disease that is passed
along at the genetic level and is so
durable that it persists in the species
to this day the tiny fraction of the
population that are immune to its
effects managed to survive but the
majority who aren't immune die shortly
after birth this is why the overall
population remains relatively low to
this day it's a disease that only
appears to affect hominids including
humans chimpanzees bonobos and
non-immune instances of scp-1000 any
hominid that lays eyes on a carrier of
the disease has a two percent chance of
experiencing immediate brain death while
a two percent chance of instant death
may not seem all that threatening at
least when compared to some other
nightmare-inducing scps the truly scary
part is that the percentage is
cumulative in other words the longer one
observes a carrier of scp-1000f1 the
higher that percentage Rises the greater
your chance of experiencing an Abrupt
death according to Foundation studies
the percentage Rises by around one
percent every 20 minutes and the
percentage also varies between specimens
with some exhibiting a terrifyingly high
death chance of 90 upon viewing this
death chance continues to occur in dead
specimens if they carry the anomalous
pseudovirus while alive though
thankfully the risk doesn't appear to
apply to small fur or tissue samples the
foundation's true concern actually goes
far beyond scp-1000 themselves because
of the species close relation to Homo
sapiens there's a worry that
scp-1000f1 could transmit to humans
causing our own species to meet a
similar or faith if humans did indeed
become carriers of
scp-1000f1 it's extremely likely that
Humanity would undergo an unprecedented
Extinction event with billions across
the globe dropping dead as brain death
sets in on mass while full extermination
of the entire species has been deemed
unlikely this existential threat they
pose to humanity more than justifies the
occasional culling of scp-1000
populations
that was a lot to take in right first
the creature we thought was Bigfoot was
actually a new species of SCP out in the
wild and second these creatures could
end human life as we know it if they
made it into a population Center but
what you're about to hear next a dark
secret only available to people with
level 3 SCP Foundation clearance is the
most shocking scp-1000 fact of all are
you ready the true secret of scp-1000 is
that what you've just heard is a lie
there is no anomalous pseudo disease and
scp-1000 poses no pathogenic threat to
humanity whatsoever who would spread
such a thing the SCP Foundation of
course strictly speaking the foundation
has disseminated two direct lies about
the nature of scp-1000 the first is that
of the disease which does not exist nor
has it ever existed the second lie is
about the creature's intelligence level
they're far smarter than the average
Chimp in fact they're every bit as
intelligent as human beings these were
all lies formulated by director Jones
and the foundation as was the very
existence of the Bigfoot myth the
foundation has been spreading
information that makes the very concept
of the Sasquatch out to be a joke for
decades all to discredit and further
push the very concept of scp-1000 into
the Shadows
but why the foundation is no stranger to
coming up with cover stories but why
would they put intentional lies into
their own files to anyone below a level
3 clearance well that all comes down to
the horrifying truth behind the origins
of today's
scp-1000 population the creatures were
first brought to the attention of the
foundation by Outcast members of the
Serpent's hand an organization dedicated
to Defying the foundation's activities
these members known as The Children Of
The Sun told them the secret history of
scp-1000 while at First Foundation
Personnel like director Jones didn't
want to believe what they were hearing
they soon came to terms with the
horrifying truth humans and scp-1000 did
evolve alongside each other with humans
occupying the day and scp-1000 the night
however while humans were still basic
hunter-gatherers scp-1000 were
undergoing vast intellectual and
societal development they were able to
create tools weapons agriculture stable
settlements domesticated animals and
event eventually even fully developed
cities it was like nothing the world had
ever seen and wouldn't see for thousands
of years to come their numbers swelled
into the tens of billions as they
created culture and Technology hitherto
unimagined including weapons of
devastating power meanwhile Humanity was
pushed to the brink of Destruction by
their competitors rapid and seemingly
Unstoppable growth it looked as though
the human species had lost the
evolutionary arms race and would have to
bow out but according to the Children Of
The Sun a trickster Forest God smiled
upon humanity and gave them the power to
use scp-1000's weapons and Technology
against them seventy percent of
scp-1000's population were wiped out in
a single horrific day known to the
Children Of The Sun as the day of the
flowers as every flower supposedly
bloomed that day during the massacre
Humanity destroyed the entire
civilization and with the same
technology they stole from these
unfortunate creatures the vengeful
humans drove the Apes mad their higher
consciousnesses were blocked out
reducing them back into the states of
mere animals once the massacre was done
and everything that was built had been
destroyed we the human race used the
scp-1000 weapons to wipe any memory of
the atrocity from our own minds the
advanced civilization of scp-1000 had
been wiped from history humans returned
to their plotting path of evolution none
the wiser for thousands of years all the
way up until today this time remained a
mystery to us so again why did the
foundation lie to us what did they have
to gain by convincing us all that it was
dangerous to even look at these
creatures while as the frequency of
sightings and the attempts of
communication increased people like
director Jones became aware of a
frightening possibility what if the
pendulum was swinging back what if the
Apes were regaining their lost in
intelligence and worse still harbored
feelings of Revenge for what we did to
their species thousands of years ago
the mere possibility that they could do
to us what we once did to them is a
chance that the foundation simply cannot
take and thus limiting contact between
humans and scp-1000 at all costs is an
absolute must however in spite of the
foundation's fears one intercepted
message from the Apes suggests that
their paranoia may be misplaced this
message translated from an attempt at
communicating with Foundation Personnel
reads simply as follows we forgive you
given choice for now not forever let us
back in it's enough to make you wonder
what species the foundation should
really be keeping tabs on here after all
when it comes to netting out violence
and death Humanity has a track record to
rival the worst creatures in the
foundation containment cells and few
examples illustrate that better than the
tragic case of scp-1000
thank you